foreign
and welcome to Simply learns YouTube
channel today we'll be taking you
through web development full codes we'll
cover HTML CSS and JavaScript in today's
video
the best way to master a language is by
programming init in this video you will
see how these three front-end
Technologies are used to create the
front end of any web page by the end of
this tutorial you will be able to create
the front end of your website on your
own but before we begin let me tell you
guys that we have regular updates on
multiple technology videos so if you are
a tech geek in a continuous hunt for the
latest technological prints then
consider getting subscribed to a YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply learn
so without any further delay let's get
started
we'll start this video with what is HTML
then we'll move on and cover topics like
HTML classes and IDs drop down in HTML
content boxes in HTML and HTML image
slider following that we'll see how we
can create a navigation bar using HTML
and CS will also work on HTML
registration forms and cover certain
interesting topics regarding HTML once
done with HTML and CSS we'll move on to
JavaScript starting with what is
Javascript followed by a first hello
world program in JavaScript we'll then
cover certain important topics like
Airways loops and objects functions and
closures promises async await in
JavaScript and regular expression in
JavaScript to email validation in
JavaScript and will end this video with
the roadmap to becoming a full stack web
developer
so without any further Ado let's start a
first topic for this full tutorial
what exactly is the basic web
architecture now web architecture is
made up of three essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data and finally there's the IP
address that is the address assigned to
a website in order to be accessible on
the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is so your browser starts by
loading the main HTML file and then the
CSS and JavaScript
the user interacts with the website and
is not concerned with the backend of an
application you have the since you've
developed your website you'll have to
host it on your server to make it
accessible on the internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of a website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly there's IP address which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an IP address
we put a domain name over that IP
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is HTML HTML is the most
widely used markup language for
developing and structuring web pages on
the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is CSS then
now CSS is a simple design language used
for making web pages look more beautiful
and presentable
it can be attached to any HTML element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is Javascript
now JavaScript is a powerful interpreted
language targeted for web development it
is used for making web pages interactive
and bringing the web pages to life
so now let's create your first website
now HTML short for hypertext markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings paragraphs div
containers tables and more HTML tags are
nested meaning there are opening and
closing tags with the content in between
those tags so now let's write a simple
HTML code that will help you understand
the basics of the language so for this I
am using the text editor that is Visual
Studio code you can go ahead and
download this text editor from their
official website so here I've created a
simple dot HTML file in my vs code and
I've added the initial HTML files
now let me explain to you one by one
now doctype is not so much of a tag but
it is more of an instruction now this
indicates the browser that the document
type to be serve the user is in fact an
HTML document now this doctype
instruction should always be included at
the very top of your HTML page next up
you have the HTML tag that is used to
contain all the web pages HTML code
right so it contains an opening and
closing tag with contents in between
them
the HTML tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the Lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page followed by the HTML tag there's
the head tag now this is the first
section of the code that contains all of
the information about the web pages
properties links and more it could have
Pages title description additional meta
tags and CSS code so here I've used the
title tag and let's give a title say
HTML
in 10 minutes
[Music]
all right you can also add CSS to the
Head tag by using the style tag and
change the display styles of HTML
elements that are being used the next
section is the body tag now the body tag
contains all the displayable contents of
your web page including headings
paragraphs div containers tables and
more
now the HTML header tags are used to add
headings to a web page there are several
types of headings available for
developers to add to a web page right so
first off let's have a look at them I'm
going to create a simple H1 heading tag
and the message I'm displaying is this
is
the first heading
all right
after this I'm going to add a paragraph
tag which creates padding in the top and
bottom of the element to help separate
the text between each paragraph
right so I'm gonna add a P tag and Save
this is the paragraph tag
[Music]
after this let me add a simple h2 tag
which is
another heading Tab and say this is the
second heading
[Music]
you can also add line breaks which are
helpful from time to time if you want to
provide a single line break in your
content you can do so by adding the BR
tag so here let me just add one for
better understanding
now the HTML div tag defines a division
or a section in an HTML document that is
used as a container for other HTML
elements now these elements can include
content areas sidebars page bars page
headers Footers Etc
this tag is used to apply styles to HTML
elements that cannot be added otherwise
you can also make use of the HTML image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a web page are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so say IMG
within which I mentioned the source
I'm adding the HTML logo so let me just
mention that here
okay
and then I'm gonna provide width for it
and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file and
when you look at the browser
you can see that uh the first heading is
displayed then your paragraph tag is
displayed followed by the second heading
and then the image now let me show you
how you can add styles for some of these
uh headings and paragraph tags so here
in back in my first heading tag let me
just say styles
and let me change the font
of the content that is being displayed
I'm going to change it to Career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so I'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when I look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
HTML tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them in your website in this tutorial we
are going to learn about the classes and
ID in the HTML and how to use them
so without further Ado let's get started
so what is an HTML cloud
an HTML class attribute is used to
specify a single or multiple class
themes for an HTML element
the class name can be used by CSS and
JavaScript to do some tasks for HTML
elements
you can also use this class in the CSS
with a specific class with a period
character followed by the name of the
class first selecting elements
so let's jump onto the demo to
understand the classes and ID better so
we are on a Sublime Text Trader
let's add the standard boilerplate of
HTML we'll give the title as classes
and ID in HTML
foreign
let's start with the basic example
we'll see how to define an HTML class
so inside the body tag
will add one H1
and will give this
a class name of
head one
will add some text here this is the
heading one
now you can copy this part because we'll
need it enough for the lines
so for the H2
this will be the heading 2
for H3
this will be heading 3.
and let's add one more H4
foreign
[Music]
so as you can see we have used the same
class name in all our H1 H2 H3 and H4
so if you save the file and go to the
page and refresh
you'll see the headings are there on the
page this is the heading one heading to
heading 3 and heading 4.
foreign
how we can use this class name for our
starting purpose
so we'll open the style tag here
and you will mention the class Name by
period followed by the class name so
head one
open the parenthesis
and let's set the color to
light sand
and we'll set the font family to set to
it cursive
keep the background color to Black
okay so you can see we have mentioned
the class name dot head head one for our
styling purposes and we have given the
color Point family and background color
for it so just save the file and go back
refresh
now you can see we have designed this H1
H2 H3 and H4 using our class tag
now let's use another example with a
different clock name
so here only will make the changes let's
name this class as H2 this H3 and let it
be H4
now you can style them separately for
the head to
foreign we can set the color
to say light
pink and we can set the font background
color to
red okay
now
similarly for the H3
Dot
H3 set the color to
foreign
set the background color to let's say
blue
okay save the file and go back to the
page
now you can see we have designed our H1
H2 H3 and H4 using the different class
name
here is the example of using the
multiple classes on the same code
now one thing you should note that these
class name must be separated by the
space
there are few points you should know
while working with the class
so the first one will be the class
attribute can be used on any HTML
element
like any HTML element can have a class
name the second point will be the class
name is a case sensitive
head one
and if we change here to say
we keep this Edge as cap capital so this
will be wrong the style won't be
implemented on the page now if you
refresh you can see the style is not
implemented
so the class names are case sensitive
let's change this back
refresh and now you can see our design
is back
so this was all about HTML classes now
let's move on to the ID attribute
so the HTML ID attribute is used to
specify the unique ID for an element of
the HTML document
it allocates the unique identifier which
is used by the CSS and a JavaScript for
performing certain tasks
in cascading stylesheet that is CSS we
mention an element with a specific ID by
using the hash symbol followed by the ID
so let's work on an example to
understand this better
so we'll use the same previous example
we'll mention the H1 and this time we'll
use the ID
so ID and we'll name it as head 1.
this is the first heading
for H2 also
will mention the ID name as headphone
only
head one
this is the
foreign
now to style The Heading we'll go back
here we'll open the style tag
and we'll use the hash chamber to
mention the ID so hash
head one open the parenthesis
we'll set the color to
light green
you'll set the font family to cursive
and we'll set the background color
to Black
yeah
okay now save the file and go back and
refresh
so you can see this works a similar
manner to the class apart from it that
we use the hash symbol to mention the ID
name
so now let's change the example and use
the different ID name for different
hedge funds
so this can be H1 this can be H2
let's add one more we'll name it as ID
foreign
okay
so we'll style the
head to
we'll set the color to red
for head 3
will set the color to Yellow
let's use green yellow okay save the
file
go back and refresh
now you can see we have the different
style for different IDs so in this way
you can use the different IDs to design
your HTML page if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
in this tutorial we are going to learn
how you can create a drop down in your
navbars using this HTML and CSS so we
are on a Sublime Text Editor I have the
dot HTML and Dot CSS file ready so let's
start by adding the standard boilerplate
let's give it a title
link your CSS file to the HTML file
now inside the body I'll add the ul's
we have added this hash so that when you
click on this home button it won't
redirect you to anywhere
so just save the file
and we'll go back to our page
so you can see we have this home here
okay so let's add some more
so just copy paste this
and we'll name this section about
now inside this about I'll require some
sub menus
so inside this I'll open another UL tag
we'll add sections such as team
clients
career and Legacy
and we'll close the LI tag here
okay now save the file and go back here
and refresh
now we'll add some more so here
we'll add the Ally for contact
okay so inside this contact I'll add the
sub menus
foreign
this code and I'll edit it here
okay so inside the contacts I'll need
email
let's hit Twitter
and this will be my LinkedIn
okay
now we'll add some more sections
name the services
and this one will be my news
okay
so this looks fine a little bit of
alignment
yeah
so you can see we have this home about
contact services and news and inside
this we have the sub menus
okay we forget to add here
hash inside the trips
just mention hash
everywhere
okay save the file
go back and refresh okay
so you can see we have this HTML ready
now let's go back to the CSS and design
these drop downs
so first inside our HTML
select the body tag
we'll add one background image so just
the background looks uh more attractive
so I have an image file saved so I'll
jpg so save
go back and refresh
yeah you can see we have this black
thing uh we'll shrink this image
so we will keep the background size to
cover
and we'll keep the font family to aerial
okay
so for the UL tag
will keep the margin to zero
we'll keep the padding to zero as well
and we'll set the list style to none
okay now we will run the UI Li part
so we'll keep the flow to left
which will set to 200 pixels
means that the height to say 40 pixels
foreign
color
[Music]
to something darker see
people dark gray okay
keep the opacity to 0.9
line height particles
uh keep the text aligned to Center
and font size 2
20 pixels
save the file go back and refresh
okay you see we have the background
image in the place we have this snap bar
in the place and all the drop downs are
here
okay
now it's time to design
UL
I and okay
so for this we'll keep the text
decoration to none
color let's keep white
and we'll set the display to block
save the file and go back
now we'll add the hover effects for this
drop downs okay
so you will Ally
a DOT power
will keep the background color for the
forward to say
any credit concept let's write calendar
save
let's see how it looks on the page
refresh
yeah it's look good
now the final part of this requires this
to shrink inside just let me hover over
this so the drop downs will appear
okay
so we'll set this UL Ali
Li 2
display none
and we'll add the whole effect over Li
and
so that when we hover the drop down
appears
save
go back and refresh now you can see all
the drop downs are inside this
when hover over it on the drop downs
appear
okay so this is all about the drop downs
menu in HTML as we saw that we can
create the beautiful drop downs just by
using the HTML and CSL nothing fancy
in this video we are going to create the
content boxes which are used in web
pages for various purposes
so let's see an example of what we are
going to create so in this video we are
going to create something like this this
is the content box with the icon and the
description of the content box
icons here used is from the font
awesome CDN
so let's start creating
so I have my two files open which is
HTML and CSS
let's add the standard boilerplate
we'll add the content
boxes in HTML
as the title
let's link our CSS file
now inside the body let's add a div
clock container
inside the disclosed container I'll
create another div box
I will require three such boxes so we'll
copy paste this three times
on the tie sheet
let's set the margin to zero and padding
also to zero
we'll set the font family
to
San serif
now
for the container class
will set the position to relative
and we'll set the width to 200 pixels
which is the whole width of the content
box
will set the height to 300 pixels
and we'll set the margin
to
240 pixels and Auto
for the boxes inside the container
will add the position
relative
and will set the width to
foreign
let me explain you what this is
this CSS type function is used to
perform a calculation to be used as a
property value
this is specifically used for the width
of the div classes
it requires a mathematical expression
the result will be used as a value
so we'll be using lot of this type
function here in this code
we will set the height to
300 pixels minus 30 pixels
one property of calc function is that it
takes single expression as its parameter
the expression can be any simple
expression combining the following
operators plus that is addition minus
that is subtraction multiplication and
division
we'll set the background
two hash zero zero zero
we'll set it to float left
and we'll specify the margin to 15
pixels
and we'll set the box size into border
box
overflow will be hidden
and Border radius
let's set it to 10 pixels
just save the file and let's go back to
the page to see how it currently looks
so you can see our boxes are in the
proper places we have the background
black with the proper margin between
them okay so we have the structure
let's code more
now we need the icon for that
will require a icon from the font
awesome CDM so we'll add the Quant or
some helium to our page
so we'll search 1000
TDN 4.7.0
we are using the older version because
it is more stable
so go to this font awesome
libraries
here select the version and copy the
link tag
go back to the page and add it here
delete this Integrity part
now
here inside this class box
add one div which will be named class
icon
inside here will add the link of the
icon so search here
font awesome icon 4.7
go to the first one
here you can search the any icon you
want uh let me search for see
foreign
so I'll go to the information
and I'll copy this
go back to the code and add it here
now inside this I'll create another div
which is before use for content
so we'll name it class content
and inside this I'll add one H3
info
and inside it I'll add some
text
uh copy this much from here
I'll delete this whole part
and put it inside
so inside the P tag
and then
yeah
so let's go back to the file and see how
it looks right now
okay so you cannot see the icon here
because it is black let's try to change
the color here
so that you can see the icon
so let's set it to sf0
okay so you can see I have the icon in
place this is and this is the text that
we have added to this content box
now let's dial this content box first
set it back to zero zero
now
dot box
dot icon
will set the position to Absolute
we'll set that top
is zero
left to zero
and we'll set the width to 100
we'll set the height also to 100 percent
background will be hash l0
and we'll set the transition
to 0.5 seconds
and we'll keep the Z index as one so
that the icon will be visible
okay
refresh yeah you can see the icon here
now let's add the whole effect on that
so container Dot
box dot over
we'll set that up to 20 pixels
and calculate the left to
50 minus 40 pixels
with 80 pixels
I keep it to 80 pixels as well
and let's set the Border radius
okay
so now that we have our app repeat
so now that we have added the whole
effect let's save and go back to the
page
now let's design the icon so container
Dot
box dot icon
dot f a
also we set the position to Absolute
top 350 percent
left 50 percent
transform let's translate it to
minus 50 percent
and 60 percent
and give the font size to
80 pixels
transition 0.5 seconds
and we'll set the color to
save the file and let's go back to the
page
yeah so you can see our icon has now
bigger size and with the hover effect it
shrinks so text to be visible
okay
now we need to add the hover effect to
the icon so that the font sizing
features
for that we'll add container
foreign
types too
fortifices
okay
now it's time to design the content
inside the container box so we'll set
container
foreign
all the positions are absolute
will set the top to 100 percent
so that when the icon shrinks the whole
text will be visible to the text box
we'll set the height
2 will calculate it
and it wasn't
foreign
Center
keep the padding to 20 pixels
for proper spacing
box sizing as border box
transition to 0 0.5 seconds
and will keep the opacity to zero
okay save the file and let's go back
yeah now you can see the icons are in
the center of the shrinking circle
now let's add the hover effect
foreign
text
okay we are not
designed yet H3 and P so let's start
designing it
so container
dot box
dot content H3
keep the padding to zero
color
and let the font size to 24 pixels
now you will see the text will be
visible Inside the Box
so we press
yeah you can see this is the heading of
our this content box
now similarly let's tile the paragraph
tag
so container
dot box
dot content
p
margin will be zero
padding will be also zero
and color will be FFF as usual
okay
yeah we are almost there
now we will Design these two boxes with
some spacing and effects over here
now uh inside this
delete them we'll copycase the above
code here
so copy from here laptop container
we'll change the icon classes here so
for this let's keep search as in rch
instead of copying the class by going
back to the font CDM you can directly
add the class search here it will know
the name of the class
and here we can add
location
so the class name for location is map
marker
here the file
and let's go back
yeah now you can see
these things are here the good content
box when you hover over this box the
this whole thing shrinks and you can see
the text visible
now ad will add some Styles will change
the color and we'll add one background
here so that when this shrinks the
background color of the black changes
okay
so we'll go back to our code
sometimes
question
anything
so to clean the color of the box
will had a DOT container
dot box
and we'll use the nth child property to
end child
one because of first box
dot icon
so we'll keep its background too
pink
okay
and Dot container
box and child
one its color will be when it shrinks
let's keep it to Orange
yeah
so save the file
go back
and refresh
okay so you can see we have the icons in
places and when you go
click on here set the hover effect
shrinks this and this is the pink in
color we have the background orange with
some text here
you can see smooth transitions
so this is all for the content boxes in
HTML you can use different icons here
using this font as awesome icon there
are several icons here you can use any
of them and just make sure that the
padding and the text are aligned in the
proper places choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
in
we learn foreign
as you can see
required images
and HTML and CSS file
so first in the storm side let's add our
radio buttons
from treatment
animated class slider
in fact if they do I'll create another
which will name the big class slice
inside the ZIP code We'll add the radio
buttons so input
the input type will be radio
and let's give this name
radio button
and we'll tag them with ID radio 1.
so as you can see
potential so we'll add three review
buttons here
so just copy paste this four times
me
here from the ID to Radio 2 review and
video code so we can distance between
the four radio buttons
so after the creative
so we'll create another div and limit
class
slide first
inside I'll create an image tag
and special part of the image
in a similar we create a few div tags
for code images
so just
will do certainly another term with
class name
slide
and inside this image
2.jpg
thank you
just save the file and let's reach your
car code
we have the reader buttons we have the
images so let's just go back to our file
and see how it looks
so it will refresh
we see we have the four video buttons
here and some distorted images
so let us fix this images in the CSS
so inside of CSS file
will add the body
and we'll set the margin to zero pixels
you'll set the height to say 100
vertical height
will set the display to select
uh we'll just Define the content to
Center
we'll set the Align items to Center
and we set the background to Black
so just
refresh this file
so it's time to fix these images
so just
set the slider bit to
800 to 12.
there's an L we'll get this breadth
we had the height to 502
then set the Border radius
to 10 pixels
and overflow will keep as hidden
for the slice part
will set the width to 500 percent
I to 500 pixels
and displayed to select
left in the file and see how it looks on
the page
so yeah you can see the images now in a
proper size you have to click this video
button we have the background black
so let's fix the scenes
so for the slide input
foreign
navigation button
so after this
has another dim
the class name
navigation Auto let's see
and inside this navigation Auto will add
Dev
class
or to button one
we need the full button so we'll copy it
four times
and this will be my button two
this is important three and this will be
button 4.
outside this they will create another
manual navigation button so we'll name
this
navigation
make sure it's published right now we
communication
manual
and inside this
book we'll add our radio buttons usually
manual
we'll name it class manual button
we need the code button so we will copy
it four times
change the label to Radio 2
radius 3 and radio 4.
so I think this will work enough so here
we have the navigation
okay we have a special mistake here
foreign
so let's recheck our code
it's a good pattern reset your code so
that you don't encounter any error so
okay we have a little class slider here
images
in selective tags with the name slide
okay we have created a navigation Auto
the code buttons and navigation manual
for the four buttons okay
so let's save the file and go back and
refresh it and see how it looks
okay
here
so inside the slides
input
filter display tool done
for the dot slide will enter
to 20 percent
and we'll set the transition to two
seconds
now we'll
add the style for image
we'll set the bit to 800 pixels
and we'll set the height to space 500
pixels
foreign
okay so you can see the images are
properly aligned here
we have to style our radio buttons for
here so let's go back to our CSS
now the code we are going to write here
rule for the manual slide navigation
let's just add here comment manual slide
lab application
foreign
will set the position to Absolute
then enter it to 800 pixels
will not have a height here we'll set
the margin
so the margin top will be minus
qualifications
and just leave it as black
and the Justified content
will be sent out
so let's do a and go back to the page
see how it looks right now
okay the images are in the center you
can see now you cannot see our radio
buttons just as now we have to add some
color to it so that the reader versions
will be visible
so go back to our CSS
we'll add the manual button
we'll set the Border
to save cheap files
solid and red
you can take any color you want
I will set the padding to five pixels
now we'll set the Border radius to say
nine pixels
we set the cursor to point pointer so
that whenever buttons the consumer heat
has a pointer
and we'll set the transition to one
seconds
say
go back and refresh
so now you can see the buttons are here
not properly spaced but yeah they are
here
so let's add the spacing and everything
else
so we'll take the manual button
like
they set the margin
right protocols
and it's time to add the over effect so
for the manual
button
the Google will be
um say background
at the law
do
so just save the file and go back and
refresh
yeah so you can see our manual buttons
are in place
when you hover over it you can see the
blue head and when you click
nothing happens right now because we
don't have in JavaScript response to
this data button we'll add them in the
end
firstly design these buttons so this has
for the panel button
now we'll add one code which will be
used when we want to select the radio
button by default
so let's understand how this video
buttons work in this
files
are identified which I'm usually
exclusive and the user has to evacuate
control
in other words we can have a
non-selected error button will erase any
of the button that is selected on the
list previously
movements
so we'll add hash video
dot check
so to find that we have added here is
more a sibling combinator
it combines two sequence as simple
factors having the same parent and the
second must come immediately after the
first
so we'll add dots first
and for this we set the margin left
to zero
okay so this will be radio 1.
the label that we added in our manual
buttons
will need four such
buttons so we'll copy this four times
one one two three and four
this will be my quality button
and we'll set the margin left here to
minus 20 pixels
or redo button 3 with 32k
minus 40 pixels
and for the last button we'll set it to
minus 50 pixels
so all this code is going to manual
navigation button now let's design for
automatic navigation button
so we open Dot navigation
we'll set the position to Absolute
then set the display to flag
it will set the upwards
to 800 pixels
uh let's justify the content in the
center
and put the margin top
60 pixels
now
so I'll add the file to navigation or to
the
so
then set the Border
to same model that they have used here
but it would shape it's a solid red
make sure you keep this secret so
Solitude and same in both the navigation
Auto and navigation manual because if
you change the color here you will see
the two manual buttons there so for just
example let's change this to Green
so when you save and
and refresh
yeah
you can see the two button here this is
the green and this is red so if there
are two colors the group of buttons will
overlap will not feel good so we just
keep it here red
and the padding to type it first
yeah
this for the Border radius to 9 pixels
and we'll set the transition to 1
seconds
now same code AS here which I added for
checking of the radio buttons
so we'll just copy this whole code
and paste it here
I'll have to tweak some pencil
so the class was navigation dot Auto
so we'll add here
navigation Auto
dot Auto button one
will set here some background
so we'll delete this group
um
background let's say
any color think
copy this code Ctrl C
and delete this whole thing and go View
and just change the radio button then
this will be radio button
this will be three
and we'll tell you phone
now we have all the designing place
now we are already designing in place
let's go back to the code and refresh
so now you'll see everything is in place
the background is that that the images
is properly aligned we have this button
so let's click
so when you click you see the images
slides the photo match
okay
second
and first so if it is ready all that now
is left is to add the JavaScript code to
this image charity function in automatic
manner so now we'll go back to this HTML
file
and below this big tag
will open once click tab
foreign
variable named counter
set it to one
open we create one function set interval
much
foreign
so it will get back to the starting
point that is one so
the whole point of this code is to
make the images slide in you know so
that's same
and go back
now when you refreshed
you see the images we move after
sometimes
specifically two seconds
now when the images become the last page
it goes back to the first
you can also change it again
manually when we talk about excellent
based development so in HTML based
development navigation is very important
where you have called multiple Pages
attached to so that when you click on
this page or click on any hyperlink it
will take you to the new page now so
that you can move back and forth so this
navigation is very essential part of any
web development so that you can offer
the navigation so this simple
application of HTML we would like to
start from scratch so let's go and
create a new folder now and give the
name called navigation
and inside this navigation we want to
create some new pages so
here I'm going to create index
dot HTML
the CSS name will be
app.css and along with this we would
like to also create some new folder
inside this I'll keep all the navigation
files inside this so I can save pages
inside this Pages let me have total
number of three pages with me when it's
called about
dot HTML
then we create
contact
dot HTML
then we create one more that is called
Services dot HTML
dot HTML so these three links we will
create it one by one but first let's
start with the index.html
so what's there in my index.html file so
first thing I would like to start with
my same HTML syntax here
well this is my basic construct
so I will start with my link Ariel from
here so that I can have my Starship with
me link audio equal to style sheet href
equal to app Dot
CSS though I have not written anything
but I just left it as a blank
in my body tag I would start with the
navigation so HTML5 brought you some new
tags known is called a nav tag which is
once again
won't change anything drastically in
your browser however they are called
cementex which will help you for the SEO
that stands for search engine
optimizations I'll start with my nav
inside my nav I will start with my div
I would say navigation bar so but before
that I said
class equal to
headache
this is my Dev tag and inside my Dev tag
I want to bring my heading so I say H4
and I said
navigation bar and after the div tag
I'll start with my URL tag which is the
unordered list inside my on audit list I
can set alike that sent for list items
and I can offer not many links inside
this so you will I just offer the class
equal to
nav hyphen
and inside this is my ni tag I say
okay which is the anchor tag
so
a link href equal to
now here I offer
the name I say index
Dot ht1 and that's it and this will be
by default active so we say class equal
to
Factor
8 plus equal to it
active and H is equal to index.html file
and here we offer oh
for home page I'll copy this line
and paste it for other three urls
so
here
the active won't be there instead we say
hdf equal to
under these pages
we say about
dot HTML and here we say about
copy this
foreign
services
contact
okay and once the nav tag is over
I will offer the div
Plus
equal to just give the name 40 hyphen
text
I just say
H1 tag inside this
and this is the home page
that's it so that's my home page which
is ready with me
and along with this whichever the other
pages are also available
those pages I also want to use so first
of all let me check how this page looks
like it
well it looks like a pretty basic page
so once this page is ready what I will
do is here I copy the content
and paste it here and above and let's
see what's there in my above few things
will change number one here
this app dot CSS
foreign
okay so rest everything is fine
so H4 navigation bar nav links here I
have to offer the links for my page HTML
page so when I talk about index.html
file
okay it won't come so
index or external file so I won't say it
is an active anymore I just remove this
line
foreign
but about would be active in this case
so
eight
class equal to
active instead of this
Services contact
is as usual same but I would not be
having any
Pages anymore
because we are in the same location
that's why and here I say this is a
about this is about which
about page
so that's it I'll go back and check
if it are fine
home is active right now about you can
see it is an about page right now about
page is just appeared as it is saying
contents are more or less looks like and
same that's why you are able to see
now just like that
I will just go back and copy the others
now here of CSS navigation bar
active
it is in contacts or make contact as an
so indextual file remain same this is
contact page
so
that's how it is and we will say about
my other properties which is my
services
let me copy it sorry
copy this contact
here
I'll be activating my
service in this case
so
class equal to active I remove it from
here
make it available here this is
service page navigation index pages
about active here or looks good heading
about okay here I change
service
it is a change to
looks fine
let's see
okay
service contact
about
so far about we need to check where we
need to go
so we have got pages
about dot HTML pages also there
so
all there so we would like to see how
the about page will be activated here so
index.html file also contains about
so here
when I
refresh
well
you have a call
index.ht Page
talk vocal about
where is that about page now
services
so like this it is happening for you
okay so that's how exactly my thing is
so we're all good
and uh
Services contact home all good well my
page is now ready and going forward we
would like to beautify my Pages by
offering the CSS well let's get started
with our CSS file so in my CSS file I
will start with my
common properties
which is margin
I'm saying 0 pixel
photo by carding
I'm making a zero pixel again
we want box sizing
this I say border
hyphen box
okay
well going forward this is my standard
settings for all different type of
properties now I want the other
properties to be getting introduced that
is for box body text
Dot
body
iPhone
text
inside is body text I said display
Flex
now what I see where the body text is
available go to my index.html file
body text is available here div plus so
here in my CSS file I can say body text
display Flex I say font family
font family I can give anything
which is giving God Bond save it
sensory
these two we are offering it later on
align items
anal item Center
followed by justify content
and making a center
then margin top
250 pixels
these are the properties out there
followed by
okay first let's check what is an effect
here
see it looks better now
if you would like to go into the nav I
already have the snap with me
no
display
s then just a quick content
space around
followed by align item
align items I want to make Center
and then we want to say mid height
so we say when
hyphen
okay so midnight we are giving 8ph
followed by background color
the 13th same color and same font family
you just copy this from currently and
make it available here well let's check
there we go so navbar looks awesome but
I still feel the links needs to be
justified we want to make it even more
better but before that I offer the nav
links so here
I see
nav links so dot nav
foreign
length
this levelings will have display
Flex
display
s and then justify contact
that I want to make it space around
again
followed by width
so
width so width would be 30 percent
perfect and now the nav link Li Dot
nav links
Li
this
let's Style
none
let's see how it is changing
there we go that it looks really nice so
nablings are ready and I want to make it
a heading background color let's rest of
the things I can just leave it as it is
now for all the other properties I can
say box sizing
support iPhone box
after that
dot container
container
and in this container we have to offer
certain benefits now first thing you
need to understand which are the places
I will be using the container so you see
here in my index.html file
when we talk about form actions and all
okay we say H1 register we haven't used
any container right now so let's get
added the container
do
class equal to
container
okay and this particular div tag will
get closed only at the last
so the strip tag
to close at the last
here so I want to make the look and feed
for this complete container
in much more better way so here in my
container we want to see
margin Auto
the center here
margin
portal now with
50 percent
then adding
so
followed by background color
which we want white
then box shadow
this box Shadow we want to give some all
four Origins 20
pics
continuation to save 20 pixel
and zero pixel
and which color we want so I just say
RGB here
this RGB just give the value called zero
again zero
the value which you would want to give
to this Alpha because it is always
between 0 to 1 we are saying 0.7 that is
an opacity
well four properties as given now let's
see how it looks
yeah why because we haven't added a CSS
in my HTML so let's add the CSS so
inside my
browser HTML
not inside my head
let me add link
are equal to style sheet href equal to
app dots uses
that's it
now let's see
there we go looks better now so this is
your container okay which you can see it
is having some Shadow I would like to
organize this all set of text boxes in
much more better way
so after this we want to offer the other
properties too looking for my input
go back to my app CSS
so after this container we want input
input again
time equal to
text
now also
to
input
type
equal to
password
here we offer few things number one
width
which is hundred percent
after
sorry
then padding
once I get 15 pixels
then margin
you're offering 5 pixels
thank you
zero
22 pixel
followed by display
I will say inline block
inline block followed by border do you
want any border so I say none
and background
we can offer the color so we can say
all right smoke
that's it let's see in my HTML
awesome so this looks more beautiful
more organized so this is
your form but I want to make it even
more better now because I want to
perform the validation and in validation
we want to check how the focus will come
in so the beautification needs to be
added more here we want to offer the
same input type text input type password
I copy this
here
now here we want to offer background
color
we want to open the background color on
Focus
this has to be your focus
focus and here also on Focus
now background color
we want to change to anything but other
typing we can just give
same and outline
no
okay so this is my for focus and for the
registration button so here we say dot
I do not have that class called register
button so I have to create this class
inside my
button
register BTN I would like to offer the
properties for those like background
color
deal
followed by color
which is
White
then padding
we offer 16 pixel
then border
no
then cursor
I think it is better to have pointer
only
then width
100 percent
solved by margin
this Auto
then opacity
and I say 0.8
5 so this is for my registration version
let's see
wow this looks better now so this is a
full size button
so this is for my button and I want the
moment I take my cursor on button
the color should change or it should
look like a hover
confidence
over
and here we say opacity
I just pick the value
that's it
now you see now the color is changing
great so like this you see how the
conditions are working on Express on
register you see the messages
please fill the field blank and it is
changing the
when we talk about the situation called
Focus so in this it works like that when
I give the name
you see now how the background color is
changing now so it is little bit more
grayish color so this time we're going
to develop another very interesting
example using this HTML JavaScript and
CSS together and that is called working
with a quiz application so one of the
very very interesting project will be
developing it from the scratcher I'm
sure that you will enjoy a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all I'm going
to give the name call
HTML quiz
now I'm going to create a three files
inside this number one I'm going to say
index.html
index.html then I need another file that
is called app.css
and the third file I'm going to create
an inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
torches
so we have total number of three files
ready with us now from HTML page we
would like to develop this HTML tags
first
so we'll go to the HTML and see
so we have got this basic HTML syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards Dev tag
so visit my Dev tag we would like to
create another div tag
foreign
class
to this particular div see we haven't
created a CSS but we would like to offer
some of the CSS classes available here
so you see
div class equal to container
now we have got another div track inside
this we will say tab
ID equal to question i1 container
question iPhone
container so that is the name or ID of
this tip and we say class
equal to height
now within this div tag we would like to
offer some details
but before that we would like to create
some embedded Dev tags inside this so
we're going to create another depth tag
here
and this tip ID
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the ID name and we would like
to offer the class also class equal to
BTN hyphen grid see again I'm telling
you these classes are just creating it
but we would like to use this in our CSS
okay so they are just the normal
classmates we are giving it right now
now insert this div tag
we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one you would like to offer few buttons
now
button so we save button class
equal to BTN
and after that you would like to give
the name called answer one
answer one so that I can have this
button class
copied three more times
and now we can change
the names to
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us Dev tag is
getting close here another tip tag is
getting closed here and now here before
the last step tag is getting close we
would like to create another div tag
now inside this tip we say
plus equal to controls foreign
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button ID equal to
start button
start hyphen BTN
okay and then we say class
equal to start
hyphen
ptn space between
and we say start here
now just copy this complete line
and put it again
so rather than giving the start button
we say
next button and class equal to
next hyphen button
next iPhone button BTN and we will give
additional property called height
foreign
next
let me make this S capital
and
next two buttons we have created
after this div tag is getting closed
after that I would like to start another
type tag
and in this type we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with a
span and here we will say span ID equal
to
right hyphen
answer
or answers I can see
so after that a deep tag is getting
closed
and that's it and it lasts the last step
tag is getting closed
which you can see it right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this Dev tag I would like to close even
before
two tip tags are getting close and this
is another tip type which is closed at
the end and here we want to include the
script tag
script
SRC equal to
script.js that's it our HTML page is
almost ready Let's review
and
yes I can see some standard buttons has
been created now we would like to look
make gives a better look and feel to
this kind of Button cell complete UI by
offering some awesome CSS
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with CSS part now
so to work with the CSS we have to offer
few things
here
we're providing a root and Victor's
wrote some basic settings we are
offering it number one
foreign
hyphen Hue hyphen neutral
hue
hyphen
hyphen hyphen Q
yphen neutral the value giving is equal
to 200.
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen Q
again iPhone wrong
this value we're giving is
foreign
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyphen hyphen hue
this we are making with a variable
how can happen you neutral the one which
we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we're giving zero
next property is merging
module also remains zero after that
display
foreign
after that width
we are providing with almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing this call
once again hundred
okay now we have called justify contents
let's justify Contents I can say Center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say Center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
in this we will like to use this VAR
again this in this world we are using
iPhone hyphen Q
and followed by
hundred percent
comma 20 percent
these things and this is style we're
going to we would like to use in my
index.html page So within my head tag
well in index.html5 how you would like
to define the style so we always use
link
CSS so the value is automatically
style.csf but we would like to change to
app
s.css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting now we want
to offer few more things into my CSS it
is only for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body Dot
correct
body dot correct
we are providing
Q
or
and here you would like to offer
iPhone icon draw
and also sorry not wrong just hold
correct
and we could use
body
dot Raw
body.com
so same thing I'd like to copy
so rather than saying correct
we're using Rock
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working for the container
foreign
I would like to offer width
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by maxword
this Max would be 80 percent
now going forward background color
background color we are offering White
that always looks better followed by
border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box Shadow we can say zero
zero
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used right
over here let's see
okay now it looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container now we would like to offer the
buttons
here in our CSS
we want to now offer the button colors
so dot
BTN
hyphen
grid
well
in index.html file so we have a call
Button grid this button grid we would
like to start from here
between grid between grid display
red
followed by grid
hyphen template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying to
comma
Auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this Gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be the 20 pixels
and then 0.
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now going forward we would like to apply
the styles of my button
so how my button will looks like in well
button grids we have created it now we
would like to go ahead with the buttons
so dot ptn
followed by the details so
I can open here
will be using neutral
also going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or I would say one pixel
and then solid
and hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
War
hyphen icon View
followed by
100 percent
30 percent
okay so these are the values for border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so in background color we will just use
hsl rather than this
so high point Hue 100 and 50 percent
okay
followed by border radius
foreign
pixels
now padding
padding just 5 pixels
and some pixels
then color
this color will be white for sure
and the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button hover
Dot vtn
Dot or
or
and for this pull forward
I want to say border color
this border color you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well so
this is how my initial looks like it
okay now I also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here we want to use Dot
start hyphen BTN
and also for
Dot
next hyphen between
common look and feel for both font size
come on
1.5
area
next font weight
now this font weight I want to keep bold
followed by padding
this padding is B with 10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with Ctrl C display
s
followed by justify contents
let's justify content service center
followed by a line
items
and here we say Center
and last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be visible to me
so the moment I said start then with
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is well my CSS is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your main code
development so here we will start
working with this const and here we will
say start
button equal to
document Dot
get element by ID and here we'll give
the name call
start iPhone BTN
that's the name like this
I just copy this line
make it available here like people call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
click here another one
here we change the name and give the
name call question
container element
container
element
question
by ID
here we give the name call question
hyper container
question iPhone
container because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there we're using question
hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called question element
question
element documented element by ID here
will be passing
question
followed by
foreign
we want to use answer button element
answer buttons element
answers
or I can say answer buttons element
answer hyphen buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called Shuffle question because
we want every time the questions to be
get shuffled
shuffled questions
current question index
Shuffle questions and current question
index
and we would like to provide one
variable called let
quiz score
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
host questions
equal to
array first question so I would like to
create it here is called question
now here we will say
foreign
JavaScript framework
so which of these
is a
which one of these I would say which one
of these is a JavaScript framework
this is my question now
okay so I would like to have answers for
sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer I
can say
like this
here I say text
first would be python
python
okay python
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false copy
now let's change the value here I say
Django
correct false
third is react
so
here I can say true
last I'm keeping it score
false as you should see
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so here after that we want to create few
more
okay so once again I would like to bring
some questions now
and related answers
so I just copy this
first
so second question
I can say
who is the prime minister of India
foreign
answers available
okay
values called for true
second we will give the name call
the value is called false
so I've taken the values like this
and we can take one more just for the
demo purpose
so
like here
next is called what is 4 multiplied by
three
I can have many answers
so I'm just making the first is called
six
it's false seconds turn
like that total we have created
three
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be known scroll clear
status class
function
here
status
class
it takes some parameter called element
and here we will say element Dot
class list
Dot
remove
Elementor class list dot remove
foreign
and once again I copy the same line
[Music]
so we have two options available
right and what wrong
now going forward we want to have few
more functions to be attached there is
only one function we've attached that's
called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
called function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second score correct
two parameters we are passing it now
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by we are saying if
correct
then
element
Dot
classlist Dot
add
correct
okay
else
else use the same option
what I will try to add from here
so this is how we would like to apply
write or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now followed by the most
important function which you're going to
use it right now here is called
your select answer so you have to
basically select the answer so this is a
little bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we'll pass e as in parameter
and from here we will reuse the const
select selected button
selected button equal to e Dot
Target
number one second const
ant correct
equal to
selected button
Dot
data set
select button dot dataset dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this set status class
function
in the set status class we will be
passing
document
dot body
as a first parameter
and correct
is the second parameter
okay now we are using
array Dot from
and here's this editor from we are using
answers
button element
Dot
children
okay followed by Dot
for each here we're using this button
as in parameter
now here what I will do here using this
option call search status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button Dot
data set Dot
we can keep the value called what
correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array now we'll be utilizing the main
evaluated value equal if
so for question Dot length
if suffer questions dot length is
greater than
current quotient index
Plus 1.
then what then we are saying
next button
Dot
classlist Dot
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be hidden
okay else
else condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot enter text equal
to
restart
okay
and next is called start button
Dot
classlist Dot
remove what we need to remove hide part
foreign
okay and here we are using this option
called if
selected button Dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document Dot
get element by ID
here we are providing
right iPhone
answers
followed by
Dot
energy table equal to
quiz score
so whatever the score will be after
selecting the correct answer this will
be available to the user
okay now the next thing which we're
going to develop it is basically your
reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
Dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
Dot
classlist Dot
add
height
okay now we are using this while option
now
answers put an element
DOT first child
so here I will be using answers button
element
child
here we have a call Total move child and
here we'll be giving
Asus button elements
Dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now we haven't called those
functions but we'll be calling those
functions one by one
but this is something which you wanted
to start with
okay
well reset state is already set now
going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
using function show cushion
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the questionary mode
so we have a call question element Dot
inner text
equal to
question Dot
question
now followed by questions dot answer
question Dot answers
Dot
for each and here I would like to use
we are passing what
answer is in parameter
now here we like to create a button
called const
button equal to
document Dot
get sorry document dot create element
I'd like to create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner text
you have to set the value
equal to
answer
dot text
Then followed by button Dot
classlist Dot
add here we are
offering
BTU
okay now you're saying if the condition
is
answer Dot
correct
if answer is correct then what
then button
Dot
dataset Dot
correct equal to
answer Dot
correct
okay now
the next thing is we are using button
dot add event listener attaching The
Listener to this event which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer whatever element
Dot
up and Joint of what
button
so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set next question
next question
function set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset State the function we are calling
it and same
and we're passing this current question
index that is what is set
next question is offering it to me now
the last function which is left that is
called start game how the game will
start
function
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
foreign
questions equal to
we have got questions Dot
sort
okay here we say
math Dot
random
and
five
we are passing this value
okay after that we are saying
current question index initially we are
giving 0 right now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
Dot
class list Dot
remove
height
okay and then click calling
set next question
which is the function we are calling it
by initializing our quiz score
with the value equals zero
well start game is
ready next thing which you have to start
the cover part
so here we are saying
start button
Dot
add event listener
here in this
on my click event
I will try to call this function
start game
first thing now next we'll be calling
next button Dot
add event listener on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we're calling current
question index
current course question index plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so we are mostly done with our code
script.js We have basically already
initialized there
okay so the values will be kept
automatically so most of the things are
now ready with us
Okay so
our JavaScript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with us now let's finally see
how my overall look and feel really
looks like it
just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome I could see the first
question appears automatically which of
these a JavaScript framework if I select
as usual my correct answers for react
now you can see is automatically making
rest of them as a red and not giving me
the next button now
it was a prime minister of India and
signature Modi create next and I say
4 multiply by 3 is at 12 I said next
and which of those used in mobile app
development flutter and flask I say
flask it says Twitter and now you can
see the application looks perfectly fine
and it gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how dear
friends your project is now completely
working and expected as a way it was
designed for when I once I can restart
and you can say start button now it's
giving me 4 multiplied by three that
means it is one second I have taken
random question this mini project will
help you to understand how we can align
our content to display to my end user so
lot many things are there we have a code
CSS in place we have a HTML in place and
using some css3 based effects using some
HTML5 based effects we will be creating
our mini website having some single HTML
page and a CSS and lot of images will
help you to understand in case if I want
to develop a website how to Kickstart
them okay so let's get started so this
is my folder I've created called Web Pro
and in a similar folder I'll be creating
some of the files so my first file will
be called styles
dot CSS so in this styles.c so first of
all I need to import some of the fonts
which I will be using it throughout my
development so I'm saying to add the
rate
import URL
and here I'll be offering the location
by saying
HTTP is
foreign
Dot
Google
apis
.com
slash CSS
okay question mark we have to use family
equal to here we can use Allura
and with using this pipe symbol we are
using josphere
truthful plus sense
so that is the URL for me in case if you
want to verify whether this URL does
exist or not so what you can do you can
just copy this
and go to your browser and try to place
this and check if it does exist yes it
does exist that means this URLs are
available to us so this is a URL which
I'll be using it for my development
after that I will be using this is as
trick and providing some of the core
features like a margin
colon zero
followed by other details okay like I'm
saying margin colon 0 and
padding once again 0 followed by box
sizing
this we are saying bottom box
followed by outline
okay none
okay and pause this we'll be offering
this style
here we are also seeing none
after that text decoration
text decoration once again none
after that font family
so we are using this
this option which you think called
joules fill
okay service double which we have used
comma
we're using one more called sense
or even sorry
so this would be a first set of the
style which will be Global to all I'll
be using this
well earlier we have given the common
style to all now I'll be giving a style
to my paragraph So
here in my paragraph we are trying to
say margin
hyphen
Bottom I want to give all 15 pixels
because I want to develop all the Styles
well in advance before I proceed ahead
we are saying font horizontal size
yeah font hyphen size that we want to
give it called 14 pixels
followed by line height
line height and 20 pixels
after that color
you can give anything
okay so there's one very common color
called light blue
for that there's only value you call
five
f
okay 80
and again 8 e
we can see that is called a kind of
light green color which is coming up now
okay which is used now a part of this
paragraph we'll be using H1 title
okay assume title and in this H1 title
we are saying margin bottom
foreign pixels
after that color
Orange
okay let me put semicolon here
along with this phone family
this form will be giving ellora
okay along with this we also want to
give queue resume
cursive okay also text
transform
this text transform I want to use
uppercase
along with this font size
this font size I would like to give 38
pixels
followed by font size
yeah so this font size I want to give is
called 38 pixels
or points that we've already given a
word spacing we have to give
this word spacing was within 25 pixels
powered by letter spacing
uh related within five pixels
so these are the details we have given
for the
H1 title okay so now we'll be talking
about our buttons which are the relation
field we have to go or provide over a
button so we are saying once again
dot BTN okay space a it means under my
button tag a what I want so I say
width
1 80 pixels
once again
yeah with 180 pixels we're giving height
35 pixels
followed by line height
line height will be given 35 pixels
followed by border
this bottle will be 2 pixels
solid
black
okay after that color
we want to give it I would say red would
be sufficient enough followed by display
I want to give it is called block
followed by margin
margin I'm going to give 25 pixels
Auto
and zero
followed by text align
okay
Center
so this is for btna which we have given
along with this between a there are some
other properties are also available like
Android
mean underscore
container here we would like to provide
position
foreign okay
colon
relative
okay after this position we would like
to also provide the property for navbar
we are saying never
underscore or let's talk about never the
rest of the stats will be offering a
little later with the snap bar we are
providing this width
okay this width will be a hundred
percent
okay this will be a hundred percent and
also we provide height
this height will be 65 pixels
okay located by position
we are providing absolute
after that we are second display
we are providing Flex
after that we are saying justify content
justify content we are seeing space
around
after that
we are saying align items
this we are giving is Center
okay along with this we are giving this
logo
of type A
so inside this logo we are saying font
family
this form firmly we are once again using
the same
the one which I have used earlier
you remember Allura and curaca let me we
can use the same whatever we have used
it earlier so same condition you can use
it here so we remember earlier what we
have used in my previous program okay
font family so the same font family I
would like to use it here also
okay so logo a but let me check
somewhere down the line
Port weight
phone family so let me copy the same
at least here right now okay so we have
a god porn family with me which we have
taken it right now to my existing logo a
along that I want to use called
font size
we would like to use 22 pixels
also color
and as usual I would like to you right
okay so that is for logo on which we
have basically applied this a part of
this we would like to also use for
navbar
member underscore
item
space equal
and here we would like to provide margin
and padding
again zero
followed by line Style
list style sorry
list
style here we are saying none see that
is the benefit of having this Visual
Studio code because sometimes when you
are going wrong it immediately will give
you the idea of like saying like hey
you're going somewhere around that's
what the suggestions were not given to
us so till here we've added furthermore
we'll be adding few more Styles into my
code well
we have seen now followed by same
dot level okay underscore
items followed by U1 which we have it
and along with this we would like to go
ahead with this list items also and in
this list items we need few details
first I'll talk about code float so
float left for sure then we talk about
color width
width will be 100 pixels
and now we talk about color height
height will be 40 pixels
well
float width height we have talked about
now we talk about called background
color
background color we can save Light
Element
that looks nice and opacity
opacity we can just give call 0.8
followed by line height
I can give call 40 pixels
okay along with this we also want
texture line once again Center
okay this is for these items now under
the same name but you may have some
other properties also
okay this is for never Uli and we can
also have the same property
but along with this Li I can also have
this anchor tag we can select multiple
elements together
so here I would like to offer text
transform
you see this textual form
uppercase followed by color
this color we are saying black
and we're talking about called text
decoration
text regulation we want nothing
along with this I won't display
and as usual it will be a block type
okay that was Li and within this anchor
tag I also can have a hover let me copy
the same
and with this anchor I can have the
property name called what
so what property you are expecting for
this
so here in my hover property I can say
background color
and I can use
tomato
okay well after this in the same navbar
items I also want to have after the
anchor tag what should happen so this
conditions I want to utilize because I
want to offer some of the animations
Behavior right over there so what
animations I would like to go ahead that
I need to offer under this navigation
items Ally so I just copy this
foreign
which we are talking about we would like
to change from
to after
okay
after so I'm removing this background
color with this because background color
can be changed to something else
so I can change to White
invite well let me have few more
properties to be get added first thing
we are trying to say call position
Position will be absolute
okay we want from left side
left I want to give 50 percent please
after this one bottle
I'm saying 0.
okay now I want to talk about what
transform
we refer to the property available in
CSS and here we are saying
Translate
X and inside this translate X I say
minus 50 percent
okay and here we are saying after that
scale
X
okay and here we're providing what zero
so that's what the condition we want to
provide it for the transform
and the next thing will be transform
origin
transform origin if I say 50 percent
and again 50 percent
after this we would like to talk about
width
width will be 100 percent
okay and we also want this height
will be 2 pixels
okay with hundred percent High two
pixels after that we talk about
transition
in this transition we can talk about
code transform
okay transform to 50 MS
it's
okay so these are so far the details
which are available with us which I
would like to use it in my code
okay that is for after of this anchor
tag so when we talk about hover you
further want to change the behavior over
there so in this case I would like to
use the same
condition I just copy that
and here let me say colon
so you can see Li
space a colon over colon after
so what conditions you want to use it
here so
transform
okay so here
translate X
okay so here you say minus
50 percent
scale X
1.0
followed by we would like to use again
Dot
navbar
okay underscore item
okay you will followed by Li followed by
once again UL
once again Li and here in this case we
want to offer display none
display
none
Okay so
that's okay and one more conditions I
would like to take it here is
here when I say UL Li colon hover so I
can say Li
Cola
over
UL Ali so we will say display
block
that's the condition
okay so so far we have written this much
of CSS we would like to go ahead and try
to implement some of the HTML behavior
and will be back to our CSS to make this
possible
okay everyone so we have developed a lot
about CSS it's time for us to move
towards our next
UI that is called the HTML part okay so
here
I've already kept it just for the kind
information I've just downloaded few of
the images
okay from the internet just to utilize
into my application
and gonna create
the another
file and give the name called index.html
thank you
okay this index.html file let me have
this template with me okay so I have a
good template with me now here uh we
want to use some of the
awesome CSS styles for of my usual
development So within my head tag I
would like to use this link
this is for CSS so say link re recorded
style sheet and href equal to now I'm
gonna give the location so this CSS
anyways is there that's called style we
want to say called styles.css and one
more style I would like to use in my
code
but the location will be somewhere else
I am saying
https cdngs
Dot
cloudflare
dot com slash Ajax slash Libs
slash font
hyphen
awesome okay that is a well-known style
sheet we are giving the version called
5.15.1 slash
CSS slash
all
sorry on Dot Min dot CSS so that is the
location actually
okay why won't we just check whether
this location does exist or not I'll
just copy this
paste it in my browser to verify
well yes this style does exist so we
would like to go ahead and continue
well I would like to give some title in
case if you want that is a call document
I can just get the link or
website
okay let's keep this little cap to cap
website development
coming to my body tag here I just want
to give a div
class equal to
let's give the name called Main
come to school
container okay and also we want to give
ID
equal to
oh that is the dev type for that okay
now along with this I want to give some
other type of Dev tags too where I want
to use it now here within this div tag I
want to give another div tag where I
want to provide a nav bar so
equal to never
okay and within this number I want to
use another div tag which says
class equal to
logo
okay within this div tag we want to
provide the HF
okay a href equal to
here we want to provide this hash
okay
and this will be provided to
home so this is we have got div class we
have a called Dev class equal to logo
and under this we are providing this
hashtag and using
simply return
Solutions
okay that is the first anchor tag the
div tag is getting closed and we would
like to start
another team tag and in this div tag we
would like to say
plus equal to
enable underscore
items
okay within this Dev type we would like
to use this you will and within this URL
I would like to use this Li
okay and in this Ally uh we would like
to bring some
ahref equal to hash
that is the link which I need to provide
okay so in this anchor tag we want to
provide a location called home here this
is the first list item which is there
like this I can provide some other list
items too like I didn't talk about call
about using hash
about and here we say
about here so this anchor tag is getting
close
okay and here before I close this list
item here we would like to take another
UL tag
foreign
we would like to paste this list item
again and here with this hash we can
just give the name call
something whichever you want to give it
again
and
empty
so after that UL is also getting closed
Li is also getting closed here
okay after this we can provide few more
Ally tags here
okay so href equal to here we would like
to provide a real URL remove the hashtag
and say
https
simply learn.com slash
corporate icon
training okay and here we're doing the
option called services
This falls into the category of what
services
like this we would like to provide one
more anchor tag for contact us
let's see
contact
one more vocal cover team
okay and here we say
our t
okay let me go back to my index.html
file and check the status
well it looks pretty nice now here we
have got simply learn solution with us
and right hand side you can see now here
in about you see how the things are
working for me this links are coming up
automatically it came because here if
you remember in my code when I was
saying this about
okay this was a part of our current code
and due to that it is now making it
possible for us and that is possible
because here in y style.css if you
remember we were using this a kind of
never UL Ally
okay so the mode I try to hover
okay so this was giving me the complete
details and due to that I was in
position to get all the details so looks
pretty nice
okay so going forward what I would like
to do is within my program as I could
see in my index.html file we have
provided this tag so UL is getting close
this div is getting close this tip is
also getting closed
okay
now here we would like to start another
table
we say Dev class equal to Banner image
minor underscore
image okay now within this tip I would
like to use one more div tag with
intensitive we say
class equal to
Banner underscore
content
okay Banner underscore content now
within this div class we would like to
use this H1
here we can say
welcome to
welcome to Simply learn okay after this
brake tag as you know that is a for
break and now
when this is pen tag we can say
words
okay
number one boot camp
okay here this one tag is getting closed
after that the paragraph tag within this
paragraph We Can Say
what
get certified
get
ahead
this value
after this the Dev tag is getting closed
the second tip tag is also getting
closed let me check
okay so that we need to organize it
uh in a better way so but initially we
have a god welcome to safety learn words
number one boot camp
how my look and feel is really gonna
help because this Banner part I want to
organize it because I do not have a CSS
for this
clear so certainly I need a CSS to
organize this particular Banner
getting it because when we talk about
code Banner content so I need to tell
where it needs to go because I also
would have some banned image also too so
I'll go back to my CSS now and in my
style CSS here
let me say Banner content
Banner underscore
content
and here we can save
text align
enter and say color
you can say
avoid smoke
okay and also within this Banner content
we want to use the H1 tag within this H1
tag you have to just set text transform
uppercase
and line height
line height 38 pixels
okay and
margin bottom
this margin bottom we want to use Swift
and pixels
okay so that's when we have it let me
close this
sorry
and here we want to use the remove
property called Banner content
with H1 and the spine tag so that I can
change the color
so here
Banner content
as well we also want to use
pattern tag within this I want to say
color and you can just say
tomato and let's check does it affect my
application yes exactly it does affect
now you can see it is somewhere coming
down the line like this
okay so I can further change it
to my application
like
if I talk about about it and all so this
I can change it for sure because if I
have some images also those images I
also want to change
towards my application but it is just a
simple part
we are talking about call Banner
and we have also have to take some
images to for this better image
so let's go back and talk about our
index.html file and see what some of the
balance I want to utilize it here
okay now when we talk about get ahead I
certainly need some of the banner image
too but Banner image is not available so
let me go back and try to use some
Banner image whichever we have to Define
under my CSS okay so here in my style
CSS let me go here and say dot
Banner underscore
image
in this Banner image we have to say
background URL
background colon or you translate URL
and in this URL we have to use this
image called images
slash P4
dot jpg
that will be my image and also we would
like to use one very common option that
is called No repeat so that it should
not repeat it and I want to fix it to
the top
and in a center
okay now let's check
perfect it is coming up but it is not
looking as good as it looks like it so
we want to use few more important things
think this background size
background size
cover and also want to use width
width I want to use hundred percent
and height
we want to use it because 600 percent
okay display
we want to use it Flex
and justify content
we want to use it called Center
and align items
Center let's check this out
okay now you can see it looks pretty
better compared to the previous version
whatever we have written it
but this image needs to be look even
more better
okay and the content needs to be more
awesome but anyways that is the first
thing which we've written after that we
have to write an About Us and other
areas but that is initially which I
would like to make it even more better
and more look
okay
okay so we have seen the value still
call option called get certified get
ahead the div type is getting closed and
I want to use another
you do and inside this div we want to
say
class equal to about
okay and
I'll equal to about
okay
and within this div tag I want to use
this H1 tag with this hatchimal tag I
said
class equal to
title
okay here I want to say
about us
as well tag is closed after that I want
to Define this paragraph and want to
give some details about a simple rule
okay like
and talk about simply learn
words number one
training okay we can just uh
provide you know some details training
providers
that's it so we can write it that much
about in paragraph tag and we can use
this table again
within this tip we say to
plus equal to
bdn and say
a
href equal to
and in this exercise we would like to
see it
colon
simply learn
dot com okay slash
resources and here we can just give the
option name call
hello
more
to this anchor type the div tag is
getting close later on
okay and now just like in there we have
provided here we can also offer the
details with regards to your services so
I can just copy the same
and provide about the services so you
can see
Services ID equal to
services and you can provide anything
whichever you would like to provide
title is the same about us we can say
our services
so we can give any details if you want
okay paragraph
now here after this paragraph using div
class equal to
div
underscore services
and we may not have any hrf right over
here so we're removing this href tag
okay div class equal to diff or signage
paragraph
d i
integral of inter Services here you want
to use another div tag and in this div
tag we want to say
equal to
enter underscore
Services underscore
item
we have to basically provide and within
this I have to use this option called
IMG SRC equal to now you have to provide
the location so I'm saying
under this images folder we have a call
services
because the Resource One
dot jpg alt equal to in case of the
service is not available you can just
say
service underscore image
okay within this once this is close you
would like to use a S3 tag now
and in this H3 tag I just say
plus equal to
sub underscore
title and here we get the title name
called
web development let me go back and check
yeah so I can see this option called
about us is coming up learn more if I
talk about learn more you see I'm taking
you to the website of this simply done
resources which are available to us so
this link is working perfectly fine
and uh I can see here called our
services
it is a thing well going back so we have
a call
this our services
so alt equal to
Services underscore image SC class equal
to subtitle web development
and uh that's it
so the div tag is getting closed here
and I may choose to talk towards Dev
service item so let me have
another div tag here and in this divide
we saved
class equal to
div underscore
Services underscore item
div underscore Services underscore item
okay now within this Dev tag
okay so what you want to offer now
I want to offer some again certain
images
so what those images will be let me try
to copy this
and the S3 tag too let me copy this
again
service one I'm giving call service 2.
service underscore images server
underscore title rather than using web
development we can say app development
okay
so this type I will copy it again which
is getting closed and try to use
one more
again images I'll say
service 3 instead service image and here
I can say online certification
online certification
okay
so like this
all the three div tags are getting close
now and after that we will start
meanwhile let me check
so these image sizes are pretty big so I
just want to make them small but
initially they are okay
okay you can see we have called our
services
Okay so
you can see like web development
so image sizes are pretty big which we
can make them small to cover up the way
they are supposed to but this way we'll
be doing a little later on let's go
ahead and talk about the complete HTML
portion which we want to complete it now
okay so till online certification we
have taken so also the three div tags
are getting closed now here onwards we
want to start another tip
of it with this tip we want to say class
equal to
equal to we want to use contractors
we want to say contact us and here
ID equal to
contact us
let me try to wrap it with this single
quotes
and here we will use this H1 tag within
this H1 tag we say
class equal to
title here and here I say contact us
contact us okay that is for the Post H1
tag we are using it now after that let's
start with another div tag with this div
we want to use class
equal to
form
underscore
wrapper
okay Del plus equal to what form
underscore what wrapper
div again
okay
class equal to
form underscore what input
and here we say
the input tag
so does the input have equal to what a
check box for me so I would like to say
text instead input available to what
text and just say remove the name and ID
and say
placeholder equal to
email okay so this div tag is getting
closed after that I can also use
so for
I would say subject as well as for
message I copy this
form input so once again placeholder
subject
and once again placeholder equal to what
[Music]
three options we are using it right now
okay there
after this once it is over we would like
to use another div tag
into
class equal to
BTN
and within this I want to use
some anchor diagram
okay h of equal to hash
instead of equal to what hash and want
to use subnet
okay that's it
now
you can see we have got these three
properties are coming up at the end
but certainly we can go back and try to
fix those images which are there behind
the scene
okay using what the style
so first important thing is we have got
this images with us what those images
are if we just check here you have a
call diff service item
okay we have a call what Dev service
item so that we want to change it but
before that I will go back to my style
and after this H1 span we want to use
for thought
about
okay dot
service we press enter
service
or I can say services
here we talk about Dot
contact us
we also talk about dot dot
our team
okay
so these four properties we are trying
to use it by saying
text align
Center and
adding five percent
ten percent
okay now
we talk about services so we think dot
services with the services we can say
background
White
smoke
now we would like to provide the tip
services where we have this options with
us we say dot div underscore
services
here
margin top
25 pixels
from margin top USA after that display
your selecting is called type Flex also
justify contents
of types based between
for depth Services now in this div
Services we may get many different type
of options
okay this is the first step service now
in the same option Dot
Dev services
and space
we talk about depth Services underscore
item
okay and here we want to save it
30 percent
okay now
I copy the screen
in this two Services item
so we want to use
image font that is the most important
area here we say width
100 percent
okay and margin button
okay margin bottom 25 pixels
okay
okay now you can see this images looks
pretty nice
yeah looks better so that's how you see
your websites are really creating some
difference compared to the previous one
now they are aligned properly and you
can see here these images are really
nice
okay that's the benefit so we have this
let me call it let's just
yeah and uh once this image part is
closed we would like to talk about H3
part
let me copy this
item
and with this item we say our strike
and this S3 will say color
tomato and margin bottom
Mr 15 pixels
okay for this S3 and when it comes to
this text boxes
certainly you can change the look and
feel how you really want it so for this
you can say dot
form underscore
grapple
or underscore
input
okay form wrapper form input
we say margin hyphen bottom
13 pixels
okay perform input
now in a similar line
uh form input we may have of our text
area
input
text it here and in this text area we
want to offer some of the details like
I'm talking about like in width we talk
about padding let's talk about like in
width I'm saying 250 pixels
okay Visa carding
we said 12 pixels
and
20 pixels we talk about
height
80 pixels we talk about resize
we talk about none
we say border
this bottle we say one pixels
call it
[Music]
um
White
this is for this and in a similar one I
can use it for the text box so form
colon input
whatever we have used it
form wrapper
form input so let me copy this
okay form input and here we say input
equal to
type of text
so what
combination you'll be using so I'll be
using width padding and border
copy
or you need to cutting any border height
and frequency is removing it
and
awesome so they look pretty nice
okay so we have this three text boxes
with us
and color looking nice the way we are
expecting from our application okay so
that's the one which my application is
offering about this text area and all so
that looks really nice the way we are
expecting right now
Okay so
what are the areas we have seen Tiff
Services item
and everything whichever you are saying
like this
so let's go back and check to my
index.html file
so we have a call
form wrapper which is the outermost
okay
you see now here it contains lot many
things
so here in my
program when I see like form wrapper
okay form underscore wrapper dot form
input and
talk about like the other details
talk about link input type equal to text
you see like the border is like that
so if you want to have this border some
different color
and certainly use black
now you can see it looks pretty nice
because earlier it was looking like
pretty much different now at least I can
see here the location has been given
okay uh so going back towards the
previous
HTML page so we had a call a submit
button with us okay after this
um
all three div tags are getting closed
and now onwards we would like to start
working with Team details
so we are saying div
so div
plus equal to
our team and uh
ID equal to
dream again
okay and now we want to use this H1 tag
here this H1 tag we say
class
equal to title and here I say
13 in a H1 tag now once it is over we
will use again another div tag which
having
class equal to our team wrapper
our
team
underscore
rubber
now within the step tag
uh we want to use one more div tag here
in this
class equal to
team underscore or team iPhone 1
phase three
div tag now here we will be using a lot
of other Dev tags inside this like
as they do
class equal to team members
team members
okay and uh data hyphen name equal to
you can give any name let's give the
name call
it's less space key okay and within this
I want to use one image tag
OMG space SRC equal to
Images slash team one
dot jpeg
okay so that's the first thing
we have it so this div tag is closed now
uh I copy the same
the total I want to use this three one
two
three and here team members I would like
to change the name here rather than it
actually let me put the name called
obviously and one more
that is called
okay and change the name to two
4.5 free
okay so this is the first div we have
used it so this div tag is getting
closed right over here along with this
this is the second type is getting
closed so after having this
two div tags closed we want to use
another one so for team 2.
okay so I just copy the same
okay uh
I would like to go ahead with
team two team so team members
and here I would like to say four five
four
five
six and change the name like you can
keep anything I just give the name
called suppose
audio
others
and
so these names we are using it now let's
go back and see how it really looks
so these images are coming like that
okay so we want to use those images in
somewhere not like this or horizontal
vertical so this for fix that issue I
have to once again look back to where to
my styles
okay where this option can be used in
better way I like to go back to my
style.css and want to use the first
option called dot over 3.
background
sorry
background now here we say
white smoke
now
again
our team
rubber
so in this I would like to say display
Flex
and flex Direction
face between
or sorry column
let's check how it really looks like it
this is a normal change
but
certainly few more classes can really
make a difference so our team
okay underscore wrapper
let's check this the same name we have
used it
is our team
now in the same way we want to use this
team
so again our team wrapper
okay
Dot
thing display
and justify contents
space between
okay
now here when we talk about t we also
want to say uh
our team underscore rubber Dot
team underscore
members
here we would like to give bit
how much 30 percent
and height
this will be Auto
and here we'll be having cursor
pointer for sure and overflow
hidden
and position
relative
this is what team members
now you can see it looks better now now
we have to basically divide those
because we have got separate team
members are available so we have to also
divide them two so here after that we
want to say
Dot
our team wrapper and again Dot
team members
a space IMG
these images we say display
blog
with
100 percent
okay
height
Auto
okay
transition
transition or transition I can say or
type all
like this
okay and in a similar way
copy this team
and we'll say members
over image
and we can say
transform
scale
1.1
that's it
okay so we have this
look and feel appeared okay with
transition image cover so they're all
ready with us
okay everybody so after writing all
those the only difference I made it like
I had used hyphen but I'm using
underscore here finally when I see my
look and feel
of this I can see now it is moving you
can see now it is all moving okay so
that gives me the confidence of like yes
exactly the code is working the way it
was expected earlier in my index.html
file
okay so once this portion is over okay
we want to go ahead so three tip tags
are getting close one two and three and
here
we would like to start working with the
footer so here we start
footer
so present this footer I say class equal
to
okay now after this I use container div
okay
div class equal to what container and
again div
foreign
equal to
footer hyphenol
call footer iPhone column now let me use
H4 within the search for I say
company
okay after this we want to use this UL
within this URL once again I want to use
some link items
uh list items within this list item
a
equal to
this hrf tag we want to save
HTTP okay we have already used the
simply learn.com URL
yeah
let me copy this
come down
https simpleton.com rather than
resources I can say about that
about hyphen us
and here we say about this
so it is getting closed
so I copy this line again
okay so one more thing I want to use it
link HR is equal to
hash and here you will say
our team
okay after that we want to offer the
careers to visit
and we want to use
careers
here
reviews
you can see
I'll even speak
so this is the detail of this so the UL
tag is getting close
and after the serial tag is getting
closed uh
we want to use one more Dev class equal
to photo hyphen column
okay I copy this
it is getting closed here
okay so div class equal to footer hyphen
column so rather than using company we
want to use this cover
discover and here in this discover we
say simply.com and here we have this
option called skill up
hyphen
free iPhone
online iPhone
okay so here we will give the name call
skill up
okay after this
we have this called careers we say
resources
[Music]
here we can give the name for resources
again
resources
we have called tutorials
tutorials
foreign
so like this we can create as my number
of URLs as I want
okay so once it is over
let me copy this again
and here photo column we say followers
follow
us
or else we can say this option name
called work with us
in this world because we can have
some options with us in UL remove those
two
in this we would like to say guest
blogging
we saved
guest
blogging
yes blogging we can say blog is kissed
blog commit
guest another link which I have it here
that is called become our trainer
here we say
become
iPhone our iPhone
trainer and we say
become an instructor
okay so like that you're offering it and
once it is done I can copy it once again
this div
and provide few more photo iPhone column
followers
okay and uh
follow us we would like to use another
tip
okay we say Dev class
equal to
social hyphen
length and this divide will be closed
later
okay table is equal to Social Links in
this I can have some facebook.com and uh
you know twitter.com and many more names
I can take it so here in our Dev class
equal to social link here I will not be
using any evil here I will not be using
any Ally here
okay so I'm closing this username
closing this URL and I like
to
well simplylamp.com or else we can just
see the name called twitter.com
okay
twitter.com slash
pin cleaner
Okay so
we can offer the user
to follow solar
Instagram also or to the Twitter also so
here we say
a hdf but what we need to give it so we
can see twitter.com
simply learn
we remove these values whichever we have
it
instead we use this I
okay and in this I I say
equal to
okay
every iPhone Twitter
okay anchor tag is closed so in case if
you want to talk about like an
typical
[Music]
you know Instagram that Instagram also
you can use it now so here we say http
www
dot install
visit instagram.com okay slash
simply learn underscore
underscore e-learning
okay and I want to use the same option
there also I
enter with this
remove this
okay so here you just give the name
called fa hyphen
Instagram
now let's go back and check
okay so you can see now we have got this
links coming up for Facebook as well as
what of this Instagram so that looks
really nice that gives us a feeling of
yes exactly the code the way we are
looking forward for it is working the
way it was expected
okay and if we want to offer any other
type of details that also you can offer
but this is the first thing which we
have taken so this is the navigation
links are available these navigation
links
you can also change the way they always
look forward for so I'll be providing
some links which we can later on use it
okay everyone so finally we are all
ready so I have basically added some of
the additional styles to my code you can
see here from this point downwards we've
added this image URL
this is for body this is for Star
container row UL this is for footer this
is for footer column so because we are
also using some photo portions into my
code as you can see we will call photo
column and photo class equal to what
footer so implemented this photo
background color equal to Black we have
used it padding 70 pixels photo column
filter column because we are using this
H4 tag also if you remember like we're
using this H4 tag also so for all H4
tags this would be the basic setting
core footer column H4 before we would
like to give the contents like this by
giving this background color height box
sizing width and a null photo column you
will and I not last side we're gonna
give this margin bottom and this is the
slide for photo column URL Li and list
items
clear and here you can see this font
size we are giving it this is for over
this is for footer column where we have
of course Social Links whichever we have
created so it is showing me that display
inline block margin border radius and
this is for Social Links when I try to
click on or over it so the color will
change to this white color and the media
this is for responsiveness to make sure
like in case if I reduce the size of my
browser they look better the way it is
expected
so another line size will change to 720
pixels so this color will be changed and
this is the styles for Arrow photo one
this is all we have implemented and
finally my application when I refresh it
actually looks like that see now this is
the photo area of my application
so I'm sure that this looks even more
better and convenient because when I try
to reduce the size you see now it's
still gonna give you the responsiveness
can you see this now this is going to
give you the responsiveness reason
because here we are using this Logic for
media when the change of width went to
720 pixels if it is going to 767 pixels
so like that you implement that so guys
our project is now ready I'm sure that
you enjoyed thank you very much for
enjoying this project so final our
application is set and our application
is working the way it is supposed to
work for us question ml stands for
hypertext markup language it is the most
widely used language for developing web
applications it was created by bernus
Lee in the year 1991 but it was
published in the year 1995. html4 was a
popular breakthrough version and got
published in the year 1991. this version
gained a lot of popularity and was
adopted all over the glow for developing
web applications so without further Ado
let's get started with the interview
questions based on HTML it's the first
question
what is HTML HTML stands for hypertext
markup language and it is the language
of the internet it is a standard text
formatting language used for creating
and displaying pages on internet HTML
documents are made up of the elements
and tags that format properly and
display it on pages
so we have our next question now what
are HTML tags so the answer for this
question is HTML tags are used for
placing the elements in a proper and
appropriate format tax use the symbols
greater than and less than to set them
apart from the HTML content the HTML
tags need not to be closed always for
example in case of images the closing
tags are not required for an image tag
now followed by the second question we
have our third question what are HTML
attributes the attributes are the
properties that can be added to an HTML
tag that change the way the tag behaves
are displayed for example an image tag
an image stack has SRC attribute with
which you can use the source from which
you have to display the image from
now the attributes are added right after
the name of the HTML tag inside the
brackets the attributes can only be
added to opening or self-closing tags
but never in closing tax
now followed by third question we have
our next question what has Mark you in
HTML Mark U is used for scrolling text
on a web page it Scrolls the image or
text up down left or right automatically
to apply for a mark you you have to use
Smart View tax now we have our first
question how do you separate a section
of text in HTML we separate a section of
text in HTML using the below tags which
are the Break Tag paragraph tag and
block code The Break Tag is used to
separate a line of text it breaks the
current line and shifts the flow of the
text line to a new line followed by that
we have the paragraph line the paragraph
line is used to write a paragraph of
text and third one the block code the
block code tag is used to define large
quoted sections now we have our sixth
question Define the types of lists in
HTML so we have the three types of
listening CML which are the ordered list
unordered list and definition list so
first we'll discuss the audit list the
ordered list uses ol tag and displays
elements in a numbered format next we
have the unordered list the unordered
list uses UL tag and displays elements
in a bulleted format thirdly we have the
definition list the definition list uses
DL DT and DD tags and displays in the
form of definition like a dictionary
next we have our seventh question how do
you align list of elements in an HTML
file we can align the list elements in
an HTML file by using indents if you
indent each nested list and further than
the parent list then you can easily
align and determine the various lists
and the elements that it contains
now we have our eighth question
differentiate between ordered list and
unordered list so the answer for this
question is an unordered list uses UL
tags and each element of the list as
written between Li tags the items are
displayed as bullets rather than numbers
now coming into ordered list so for
creating an ordered list you'll be using
ol tax and each element inside the list
as written using l i tags the list items
are displayed using numbers rather than
bullet points now we have a sample on
the screen right now so the first three
elements are a set of unordered lists
which are represented using bullet tax
and the second set which is the coffee
tea and milk is an ordered list which is
represented using numbers
now moving ahead we have the ninth
question how do you display a table in
HTML web page so the table in HTML can
be created or displayed using the table
tag
so it also uses to manage the layout of
the page for example had a section
navigation bar body content photo
section etc etc so given below our list
of HTML tags used for displaying table
in an HTML web page so we have table TR
th etc etc table is used to define a
table TR is used to define a row in a
table th for header TD for a cell
caption is used to define a caption and
we have the call group which is used to
specify a group of one or more columns
in a table for formatting next we have
call which is used with call group
element to specify column properties for
each column next we have t body which is
used to group The Body content in a
table next we have t head T footer which
are used for header content and footer
content respectively moving forward we
have our 10th question how do you
display the given table in an HTML web
page so the answer for this question is
written on the right side part of my
screen this is the sample code which you
can use to represent order display a
table which is given in this particular
format over here now followed by this we
have our 11th question how do we insert
a comment in HTML so the answer for this
question is we can insert a comment in
HTML by beginning with lesser than sign
and ending with a greater than sign for
example as shown in the right side part
of my screen which is hello world now
moving ahead we have our 12th question
how do you insert a copyright symbol in
HTML so you can insert a copyright
symbol by using Ampersand copy semicolon
or Ampersand hashtag 169 semicolon in an
HTML file now moving ahead we have our
13th question so what is a white space
in HTML so the answer for this question
is an empty sequence of space characters
is called as white space in HTML this
white space is considered as a single
space character in HTML white space
helps the browser to merge multiple
spaces into one single space and so
taking care of indentation becomes
easier
white space helps in better organizing
the content and tax making them readable
and easy to understand with this let's
move into the 14th question
how do you create links in different
sections within the same HTML web page
so the answer is Anchor tax we can use
anchor tag along with referencing
through the use of hashtag symbol to
create several links to different
sections within the same web page moving
ahead we have the 15th question how do
you create a hyperlink in HTML so the
answer is we can use anchor tag again
here the same thing we can use anchor
tag to create a hyperlink within the
HTML that links to another web page the
hyperlink can be added to images too now
moving ahead into our 16th question
Define an image map so the answer for
this question is an image map in HTML
helps in linking with the different
kinds of web pages using this single
image it can be used for defining spaces
in the images that are made part of the
image mapping process
moving ahead we have our 17th question
why do we use stylesheet in HTML a
stylesheet helps in creating a
well-defined template for HTML web page
that is both consistent as well as
portable a single style sheet template
can be linked to various web pages which
makes it easier to maintain and change
the look of the website now the 18th
question what is semantic in HTML so the
answer for this question is semantic
HTML is a coding style it is the use of
HTML markup to reinforce the semantics
or the meaning of the content for
example the semantic HTML B tag is not
used for bold statement as well as itac
which is not used for italic instead we
use strong and EM tags now followed by
the 18 question we have our 19th
question what is SVG in HTML so the HTML
SVG is used to describe the vector or
raster Graphics SVG images and their
behaviors are defined in XML text sheets
it is mostly used for Vector type
diagrams like pie charts two dimensional
graphs in an x y coordinate system now
moving ahead we have our 28th question
what would happen if there is no text
between the HTML tags so the answer for
this question is really simple there
would be nothing to format if there is
no text present in between the tags
therefore nothing will appear on the
screen some tags such as the tax without
closing tag like image tag do not
require any text between them
now followed by the 28th question we
have our next question how do you create
nested web pages in an HTML so nested
web pages basically mean a web page
within a web page we can create nested
web pages in HTML using the built-in
iframe tag the HTML live frame tag
defines an inline frame for example
which is displayed on the right side
part of my screen you can see the iframe
source let's redirects the user to
Simply learns official webpage
now followed by that we have our 20
second question how do you add buttons
in HTML so we can use the built-in
button tag in HTML to add buttons to the
HTML web page so on the right hand part
of my screen you can see the
implementation of button to an HTML web
page now followed by 20 second question
we have our 23rd question what are the
different types of headings in HTML so
the answer for this question is there
are basically six types of heading tags
in HTML which are defined with H1 to H6
tags
each type of the heading tag displays
different text size from another where
H1 is being the largest and H6 is being
the smallest so on the right hand part
of my screen you can see the
implementation of heading tags from H1
to H6 now the
output for this particular code segment
is the H1 H2 h3h4 H5 H6 so you can see
that H1 is being the biggest one and H6
is being the smallest one now moving
ahead into our 24th question how do you
insert an image in the HTML web page so
the answer for this question is you can
insert an image in the HTML web page by
using the following code which is
displayed on the right side part of my
screen you can see we have a image
source is equals to tulip.jpeg which is
used for inserting an image into your
HTML web page
now our 25th question what is the alt
attribute in HTML now the answer for
this question is the alt attribute is
used for displaying the text and place
of an image whenever the image cannot be
loaded you to any technical issue so
basically when you have poor internet
connection and you are trying to load an
image you can see some sort of text in
place of an image so that particular
text is nothing but the alt attribute
now moving ahead we have our 26th
question how are hyperlinks inserted in
the HTML web page you can insert a
hyperlink in the HTML web page by using
the following code which is present on
the right side part of my screen you can
use the anchor tag along with h
reference and inside that particular tag
you can use the URL to which you want
your users to redirect to now followed
by this we have our 27th question how do
you add color to the text in HTML
so the answer for this question is you
can add color to the text by using the
following code which is present on the
right side part of my screen where you
can add a red color and blue color green
color to this particular paragraph and
headings now followed by 27th question
we have our 28th question how do you add
CSS styling in HTML so there are three
particular ways to add CSS to your HTML
there are inline CSS external stylesheet
and internal style sheet we'll discuss
each of these methods in a bit more
detail first we have the inline CSS so
it is used when less amount of styling
is needed or in cases where only a
single element has to be styled to use
inline Styles add the style attribute in
the relevant tag now moving ahead we
have the external style sheet this is
used when the style is applied to many
elements or HTML pages each page must
link to the style sheet using the link
tag
now we have the last one which is the
internal style sheet it is used when a
single HTML document has a unique style
and several elements need to be styled
to follow the format internal stylesheet
is added in the head section of the HTML
Page by style tag now followed by this
we have our 29th question what hierarchy
do the style sheets follow
the answer for this question is if a
single selector includes three different
style definitions the definition that is
closest to the actual tag takes
precedence inline style takes priority
over embedded style sheets which takes
priority over external style sheets now
our last question for the session today
how do you add JavaScript to an HTML web
page so the answer for this question is
we basically have three methods to add a
JavaScript to our HTML webpage they are
inline script block and external
Javascript file first we'll discuss the
inline you can add JavaScript to your
HTML elements directly whenever a
certain event occurs JavaScript code can
be added using attributes of the HTML
tags that support it now the next one
that is the script log you can define a
script block anywhere inside the HTML
code which will get executed as soon as
the browser reaches to that part of the
document this is why script locks are
usually added at the end part of the
HTML documents now the last one that is
the external Javascript file you can
also add or import the JavaScript code
from a separate file and keep your HTML
code clutter free this is especially
useful if there is a large amount of
scripting added to the HTML web page so
this session will be about become a
front-end developer so let us begin
we are going to discuss the things you
need to know to become a web developer
first we will start with basic skills
which every web developer must know
before moving into more advanced web
Frameworks then we will understand what
react is and why it is so popular after
that we will go through another web
framework called angular
then we will also get to know about a
comparatively new front-end framework
called view in the end we will go
through the front-end developer salary
Trends which will give you an Insight of
the job market
so without further Ado let's get started
first the basic skills let us understand
what basic skills are required to become
a web developer there are a few
recommendations in that you must learn
for either path these are the common
things every programmer should know
the first one is the GitHub
so git is a free open source version
control system that enables
collaborations in a particular project
it is designed to handle both small and
large-scale projects git is a tool used
to save code and create different
versions to better manage the feature
updates in the product or an application
so followed by the GitHub the next
important thing we have is today
structures and algorithms a data
structure is a location used to store
and organize data an algorithm is a
collection of steps to solve a
particular problem
learning data structures and algorithms
allow us to write efficient and fast
computer programs
so followed by data structures and
algorithms we have the text editor get
familiar with the text editor of your
choice
Visual Studio code is the top choice for
most of the web developers and my
personal choice too because of the large
support of languages and of course the
speed
the text editor is where you write all
your code and the terminal is where you
execute it
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line the command line is an
important tool to get familiar with it
is how you run your code after writing
it on a text editor
the better you are on the command line
the more efficient you will be asked
developer
so followed by the command line we have
the HTTP and https the HTTP protocol is
the backbone of the internet
it handles requests and responses from a
web application it is mandatory for a
web developer to have good knowledge of
both HTTP and https in order to build
fast and responsive web applications
now that we know what basic skills are
required to become a front-end developer
let's discuss about the most popular
front-end library that has to react
now what exactly react is
so react as a front-end JavaScript
library used for building beautiful user
interface components
it is an open source meaning it can be
used in your commercial projects without
any restrictions
it is also component based and these
components can be used again and again
promoting code reusability
it is an MVC or model view controller
architecture react as the V responsible
for how the application looks and feels
for the end user now why should you
learn react react has always been in
high performance as it uses virtual Dom
rather in real Dom so basically Dom
stands for document object model and is
used by every internet browser for
rendering a web page or an application
react can also be easily integrated with
other JavaScript Frameworks like node.js
resulting in the development of a
completely new web application including
front-end and the backend
it is comparatively easy to maintain
large scale applications written in
react because it highly promotes code
reusability and code readability
so followed by react the next important
thing we have is the angular
we have an idea of what react is but it
is not the only framework used for
building user interfaces so now let us
know about angular
so now what exactly angular is
angular unlike react is a fully fledged
framework for web application
development which usually does not
require additional libraries for
implementing additional functionalities
like routing
it is also open source and backed by
Google and as regularly updated
resulting in constantly improved
performance and addition of new features
in terms of performance at respect to be
much slower than react but with the
recent versions performance seems to be
on par with react
now why should you learn angular angular
is one of the most stable Frameworks out
there it is also the most complete
meaning you don't have the need to
integrate with other Frameworks since
it's pretty much includes everything for
the web development of a complete web
application
angular backed by Google is safe choice
for using in long-term projects since it
is not going anywhere anytime soon
angular is obviously used by Google for
its web applications and also used by
other large-scale companies creating a
lot of job opportunities now followed by
angular the next one we have is the view
now that we know quite a bit about the
two popular front-end Frameworks namely
reactant angular let's now go ahead into
view and learn a bit more about view.js
Library
now what exactly is View
view as a lightweight and open source
Progressive JavaScript framework used
for developing interactive web user
interfaces
it is meant to be integrated with other
libraries to develop a complete web
application
like react vue.js is mainly focused on
The View part of the web application and
hence its bit faster when compared to
angular which has a complete web
application solution
view.js is commonly referred to as View
and pronounced as vue.js or view is
rightly so
now why should you learn View
any beginner web developer can easily
understand View and start building their
own web user interfaces
like react view also uses virtual Dom
result again better performance and it
also uses the component based code
design promoting code reusability and
code readability
vue.js has become popular in recent
times and many companies are starting to
use it owing to its lightweight
performance and easy integration with
other web libraries and Frameworks
now with this let's move into the next
section where we will discuss about the
front-end developer salary trends now
that we know what skills we need to
become a front-end developer let's now
have a look into the cell regions of a
front-end developer
front-end developers are always in high
demand since new web applications are
launched and managed continuously
there are generally offered gender
salaries across the globe
the salaries also depend on the factors
like Frameworks skills and the work
experience the average salary of a
front-end developer in India is 5 lakh
six thousand rupees per annum the
average salary of a front-end developer
in United States is 76
929 US dollars per annum this session
will be about web development roadmap in
2021 so let us begin
assuming that you know what web
development is the roadmap is divided
into three sections the first section is
all about the common skills which every
web developer should know while the
second and third are about front and and
the back end development the main areas
of web development
so you can either learn front-end or
backend or both depending upon your
choice so if you want to become a full
stack web developer then you have to
learn both front-end and the back end
there is no escaping there in the end we
will also go through the salaries of web
developer so without further Ado let's
get started
the first one that is the common skills
let us understand the basic skills that
you require to become a web developer
there are a few recommendations in that
you must learn for either path these are
the common things every programmer
should know
the first one is git get is a free and
open source version control system that
enables collaboration in a particular
project it is designed to handle both
small and large scale projects
git is a tool used to save code and
create different versions to better
manage the future updates in a product
or application
the next one is the data structures and
algorithms a data structure is a
location used to store and organize data
an algorithm is a collection of steps to
solve a particular problem
learning data structures and algorithms
will allow us to write efficient and
fast computer programs
followed by data structures we have the
text editor
get familiar with the text editor of
your choice next Visual Studio is a Top
Choice of the most web developers and my
personal choice too because it has a
large support of languages and of course
the speed
next text editor is where you write all
your code and the terminal is where you
executed
so followed by the text editor we have
the command line
a command line is an important tool that
you need to get familiar with it is how
you run your code after writing your
code on the text editor
the better you are on the command line
the most efficient you will be as a
developer so followed by command line
interface you have the HTTP or https the
HTTP protocol is a backbone of the
internet it handles the requests and
responses of a web application
it is mandatory for a web developer to
have good knowledge of both HTTP and
https in order to build a fast and
responsive web application
so followed by Common skills we have the
front-end developer
front-end development is all about
developing the user interface and its
interaction with the client end let's go
ahead and look into this field of web
development there are a few things that
you must know for becoming a front-end
developer let's discuss these things
so the first one is the web development
Basics it is necessary to know the
basics of web for moving on to
programming languages next you should
know stuff like a web applications
protocols like HTTP and web development
in general so followed by web
development Basics we have the HTML and
CSS HTML and CSS are the backbones of
any website HTML provides the structure
while CSS provides the style to make
them visually appealing
mastering these two technologies is a
must to become a front-end developer
browser in the end renders HTML and CSS
on the web page regardless of the
technology used to develop that page
followed by HTML and CSS we have the
JavaScript JavaScript is an extremely
important technology that every web
developer should learn most of the
popular web Frameworks like react.js and
node.js are built upon the JavaScript
JavaScript makes the web application
select by adding interactivity and
dynamic updating of web applications
followed by JavaScript we have the
typescript
typescript can be considered as an
extension of JavaScript angular uses
typescript as its base language it adds
type safety to JavaScript to catch
errors in the development phase it also
helps in developing object-oriented code
for JavaScript so followed by typescript
we have the angular
angular is a web framework used to
create a single phase applications
it is packed by Google therefore
learning angular is a good choice for a
modern web developer
so followed by angular we have react.js
react is a popular library for
developing fast and responsive web
applications
it is backed by Facebook and quite
popular because of its Simplicity and
performance
it allows you to create a reusable
components that can be used to create
modern web applications
so followed by react.js we have view JS
view is like other front-end Frameworks
that is used for building user
interfaces
it is comparatively easier to integrate
view with other libraries or existing
projects
it is a newer framework but it has
really picked up speed last year and
being adopted more
now followed by the front-end developer
we have the backend Developers
so back-end development is more about
hearing how application works and ensure
that it keeps running smoothly let's go
ahead and know more about this field of
web development there are a few things
that you must learn from becoming a
back-end developer let us discuss those
things
so the first one is the node.js node.js
is a JavaScript runtime built on
Chrome's V8 JavaScript engine it allows
you to develop a complete web
application using JavaScript
it is best suited to be used for web
applications in conjunction with
JavaScript Frameworks like react.js
so followed by node.js we have python
python is a popular language used in
various fields of tech applications
Django is a backend framework based on
python used for server-side scripting it
is also known for its speed and
efficiency python is also a easy to get
started with programming language if
this is your first time coding followed
by python we have Java
Java has been the most used language for
a long time it is primarily used for
backend development you can either use
core Java or Java with springboard for
high performance backend next we have
next we have Ruby Ruby is a dynamic
programming language that focuses mainly
on Simplicity it has a syntax that is
very easy to read and close to English
language phrases
the web framework Ruby on Rails is
popularly used for developing packing
systems so followed by Ruby we have PHP
and MySQL PHP although rooted as a hard
to learn language is still the easiest
way to write a server-side code at least
50 percent of the internet runs on PHP
and MySQL
MySQL is the most popular database for
storing data of a web application now
followed by the backend developer we
will enter the next important stage of
web development roadmap in 2021 that is
about the web developer salary Trends
let's now have a look on the salary
trends of a web developer web developers
are always in demand since new web
applications are launched and managed
continuously they are generally offered
generous salaries across the globe
salaries also depend on the types of web
Developers for instance full stack
developers are paid more than the
front-end and patent developers the
average salary of a web developer in
India is 3 lakh 86 000 per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the United States is 68
524 US dollars per annum I'm sure you've
all heard the phrases software
development and web development
and I wouldn't be surprised if you use
them interchangeably or even mistook a
software developer for a web developer
well let me break your bubble they are
different today's topic of discussion is
software developer versus web developer
so moving ahead who is a web developer
now a web developer builds and maintains
websites and other web applications he
takes web design and turns it into a
website
web developers are responsible for how a
website or web application looks and
functions from its user interface and
page layout to back-end systems for
Gathering data a web developer is
expected to collaborate with clients
stakeholders and organization leaders to
design unique and engaging websites for
businesses non-profits government
agencies and anyone else who's looking
to communicate more effectively online
so diving a bit deeper a web developer
can specialize in different areas based
on their skill
you have the front-end developers now
these are experts who are in charge of
how websites and applications look and
function from the user's perspective
next there are back-end developers who
focus on the technical aspects of
websites and web applications that
support both basic and advanced
functionality
now they largely work on administrative
components which include databases
website architecture application logic
creating new apis and user interfaces
based on predefined specifications
and lastly there are full stack
developers who are professionals
responsible for the development of an
application from start to finish they
specialize in both front-end and back
end of the application development
typically a web developer should have
good skills in various Frameworks and
markup languages like HTML CSS
JavaScript
react shares angular and database
Management Systems like mongodb and back
in tools like node
so I hope this helps you understand who
a web developer is some of their
responsibilities and their basic skill
set
next up let's understand who a software
developer is
now software developers are responsible
for creating more complex applications
and programs for computers and mobile
devices
they create conceptualize program
document test and upgrade software and
their components
software developers invent manage and
optimize computer programs that run on
desktops laptops smartphones and other
mobile devices
these computer science professionals
write complex code that governs how
desktop applications function
they also specialize in troubleshooting
code bugs updating user interfaces
creating new tools and much more
just like web developers Professionals
in this field are often categorized into
specific roles based on their
specializations
we have the application software
developer and the system software
developer now an application software
engineer is a professional who focuses
on designing specific desktop and mobile
applications tools and games for
Consumer audiences
and the system software developer is
largely concerned with designing systems
level software for Enterprise customers
rather than the public
the software they develop is used to
manage corporate Network apps database
Management systems and other critical
infrastructure
talking about their desirable skills
they need to be proficient in
programming in the field of JavaScript
Java c-sharp PHP Python and Ruby they
must also have a good understanding of
operating systems Network and database
management
so now moving on to the main topic of
discussion software developer versus web
developer
first let's compare the two based on
their prowess or area of expertise
the software developer is associated
with developing products that can be run
on multiple systems
this product could be any kind of
software
their area of work includes requirement
analysis planning coding testing of
applications implementation deployment
and maintenance
talking about web developers they are
responsible for the development of
websites they're also expected to follow
the process of the software development
life cycle while building their products
next up is the type of product
now a software developer creates
programs for Standalone desktop or
mobile platforms
on the other hand a web developer takes
care of the web framework server-side
functions API integration and the
business logic
the third point of comparison is product
compatibility
now software development applications
are compatible across multiple operating
systems or platforms
the web applications on the other hand
are designed to be compatible across
multiple web browsers
next up is the learning curve
well software engineering never focuses
exclusively on coding
however you should know at least a
couple of languages and a deeper
understanding of how they function
some of the languages that you should be
proficient in include Java c-sharp
Python and some of its libraries and
Frameworks JavaScript and Ruby among
others
a web developer should be familiar with
markup languages like HTML CSS
JavaScript libraries and Frameworks like
react and angular
he should also have a good hold of
back-end Frameworks like python Django
and node
the next parameter is a job title now
there are different job titles for these
professions some of them for software
development are software developer
software engineer Junior software
developer senior software developer and
a software architect on the other hand a
web developer could receive titles like
front-end developer back in developer
full stack developer or just a web
developer now of course companies have
discretion over assigning these job
roles to their employees
lastly let's look at the job outlook and
salaries
now the job growth projections for
software developers are even more
optimistic than those for web
development roles alongside promising
job growth software developers also have
higher salaries than other it
professionals
now the average salary of a software
developer in the US is around 76 000 US
dollars per annum and the average salary
of a software developer in India is
around 5 lakh Indian rupees per annum
for a web developer the average salary
in the US is around 68 000 US dollars
per annum and in India it's around 4
lakh Indian rupees per annum
now I'm sure you must be confused as to
which one to choose
well to be frank it's just a matter of
preference if you have strong knowledge
of data structures file systems
algorithms Source Control operating and
network systems then software
development would be a better choice
but if you have creative ideas for
websites love designing them have a good
understanding of HTML and CSS and
ultimately The Knack to integrate your
design ideas to create responsive user
interfaces then a web development role
could be a good career path
then web development could be a better
career path to choose today's topic is
web developer versus a web designer now
it is extremely common to get confused
between a web developer and a web
designer now these roles are used
interchangeably given their names and
dependency on each other however there
are a few differences among them people
aspiring to get into web development
often ask me which role is suitable for
them or rather where do they fit in or
what has to be done during the process
of web development
so I've particularly kept this session
clear to clarify all your doubts and
provide an insight into both web
developer and web designer roles and
their responsibilities
so let's begin
first let's look at what's in store for
us
we'll first look at what web development
is
then we'll understand who exactly is a
web developer
after that we will have a look at what
web designers actually do
moving ahead will compare between web
developers and designers to give you a
greater insight into both the roles
then we look at the current salary
trends of a web developer and a designer
in the tech industry
and lastly we'll conclude with deciding
which role to go for
so without further Ado let's get started
what exactly is web development
so web development is a process of
building websites and applications for
the internet
now keep in mind that web development
and web design is seen as different
fields in most of the use cases even
though they collaborate together to
provide the end result that is a web
application
so the web development can be broken
down into three layers that is the
client-side coding which includes the
front end then you have the server side
coding which is the back end and then
you have the database Technologies
but who exactly is a web developer
now that we know what web development is
let's understand this
so here are some of the Technologies
used by a web developer there's HTML for
web layout
CSS for web styling JavaScript for
making web applications more responsive
and Interactive there's react.s which is
a JavaScript framework used for
front-end development
and then there's node.js which is a
JavaScript framework again used for
server side development
there's mongodb which is a database
technology for storing data for web
applications
and then there's also angular which is
another front-end development framework
based on typescript
now there are many other Technologies
like PHP Java Ruby Etc
and these are most commonly used by all
the web developers but you might be
wondering who a web developer is now the
role of a web developer is to build and
maintain websites
he also takes a web design which has
been created by either a client or a
design team and turns it into a website
now web developers are also responsible
for building a product that meets both
the clients needs and those of the
customers and the end users
web developers collaborate with
stakeholders clients and designers in
order to understand the vision
a web developer also has to perform
specific tasks
however these responsibilities may vary
depending on whether they're working as
a front-end back-end or a full stack
developer generally full stack
developers specialize in both the front
end and the back end
so let's go ahead and know more about
each type of web developer in this field
now there are basically three types of
web Developers
there's a front-end developers who build
and maintain the client side of an
application
then you have the backend developers who
work behind the scenes and manage the
services of a web application
and finally you have full stack
developers who manage the project
workflow and work on the required
features of a web application
now let's look at each role in detail
first up when it comes to front-end
developers they usually code the client
side of a web application while the
backend developers build and maintain
the services needed by a web application
behind the scenes and then you have the
full stack developer whose prowess is in
both front-end and back-end development
now front-end developers convert the
design into a real-life application
using HTML JavaScript and CSS
back-end developers on the other hand
ensure that the web applications keep
running smoothly and full star
developers supervise the development and
guide on best practices
front-end developers ensure responsive
and adaptive user interface for your
applications
back-end developers manage services like
API data storage for the web application
and so on
and full stack developers know both the
business requirements and the user
interface requirements
now let's go through the skill set of a
web developer the skills that a web
developer must have are HTML that is the
markup language for building web page
layouts
CSS which is the style sheet for styling
the HTML elements in a website
there's JavaScript which is a scripting
language for bringing web applications
to Life by making them more interactive
and responsive
and he should also know front-end
Frameworks like react angular view that
help in making the client side of
applications look better and speed up
the development
moving on you have the backend developer
skills
there's PHP which is the backend
language that helps in maintaining all
the work that happens behind the scenes
in a web application
and then there's python which is a very
popular language used in various
software development Fields it is used
to handle server-side tasks in web
development then there's Java which is
one of the most used languages for
software development and therefore is
also used in backend development by
developers and then there's database
management so databases like MySQL and
mongodb are used for storing data for
web applications
now full stack developers have skills
that cover both front-end and back-end
development of a web application
therefore they manage the workflow of a
web application development environment
moving on who exactly is a web designer
now here are some of the Technologies
used by a web designer this Adobe
Photoshop for image editing and web
design
there's Adobe Illustrator for working
with vectors and scalable web elements
sketch for Designing user experience for
web applications
Adobe XT also used for user experience
design of web and mobile applications
Adobe InDesign for marketing campaigns
like banners posters and magazines there
are many other Technologies like Adobe
After Effects blender that are used by
web designers as well but you might be
wondering who exactly is a web designer
so web designer is one who plans and
Designs the layout and other elements of
a website or an application
he performs digital retouching along
with image editing or video editing in
some cases
web designers are responsible for
designing a product that meets both the
clients needs and those of the customers
and end users
he also designs products that are
user-friendly appealing and Visually
effective
the design is preferably modern and also
easy to use at the same time
so let's go ahead and know more about
the design role
some of the popular design roles include
web designers who design websites and
its elements there's ux designers or
researchers who are responsible for the
user experience of a web or a mobile
application
there are multimedia Specialists who
specialize in handling media for web
applications like images and videos
and then you have game designer which is
another role that employs similar tools
as that of web design like Adobe
Creative Cloud now let's look at each
role in detail a web designer designs
the look of websites and its elements a
ux designer designs and prototypes the
look and feel of web applications and
mobile applications
a multimedia specialist handles media
requirements like editing images videos
Etc and then you have the game designer
who designs the props and characters of
a game for various platforms
a web designer typically uses tools like
Adobe Photoshop and Adobe Dreamweaver
a ux designer uses tools like Adobe
Illustrator sketch Adobe XD
a multimedia specialist mainly uses
Adobe Creative Cloud which includes
Photoshop illustrator and after effects
and then the game designer uses tools
like Adobe Illustrator Autodesk software
blender and unity
so let's go to the skill set of a web
designer
the skills that a web designer must have
Adobe Creative Cloud this is the
industry standard software for web and
multimedia design a web designer must
have an imaginative mindset to design
modern web elements a web designer must
also be creative enough to make the app
look visually appealing he must also
have the ability to give attention to
detail for minor features and
improvements in the web or mobile
applications some of the other swap
skills include communication skills
collaborative mindset and patience
so now let's make a detailed comparison
between web developer and a web designer
so to summarize we've put together a
table for you so web developer builds
web applications using languages like
HTML CSS and JavaScript while a web
designer designs the web applications
using tools like Adobe Photoshop or
sketch
a web developer frequently uses
JavaScript Frameworks for more
streamlined development while a web
designer uses Adobe Creative Cloud for
most of the design needs
a web developer should possess good
coding skills while a web designer
should have good graphic design skills
web developers have to keep themselves
up to date with the latest web
Frameworks and libraries while web
designers have to keep themselves
updated with the latest design Trends
and color palettes
so going ahead let's look at the
industry trends
web developers usually have a trend of
earning more than the web designers
still it depends on how well you perform
in your particular job role so if you're
good in web design you might actually
earn more than a fellow web developer
so the average salary of a web developer
in India is around 3 lakhs 90 000 rupees
per annum
the average salary of a web developer in
the United States is around 68 000
dollars per annum
the average salary of a web designer in
India is around 3 lakh sixty thousand
rupees per annum
while the average salary of a web
designer in the United States is around
53 000 US dollars per annum
so moving to the most important question
which one should you choose
it is really a matter of preference
if you have a creative vent of mind and
enjoy using good looking web and mobile
applications and also enjoy designing
them then I would suggest you go for a
web or ux designer role if you have a
technical background like Java or Python
and you're interested in bringing the
designs to life I would suggest you go
for a web developer role now that you
have learned all about HTML let's move
on to CSS here we'll discuss CSS
selectors CSS Box model CSS grid layout
and flexbox CSS display CSS positioning
difference between flexbox and grid lcss
background image and colors then we'll
move on to discuss CSS keyframes and
animations CSS Transitions and hover
effects CSS navigation bar after
learning this much we look at some
tricks that come in handy when you write
the code after that we look at CSS
Advanced tutorials and responsive design
at last we learn some important
interview questions that are frequently
asked
what are CSS selectors
CSS selectives allow you to select and
style HTML elements selectors are used
to find elements based on their ID
classes types attributes value of
attributes and much more let's discuss
the most common selectors there are
several different types of CSS selectors
the most common of them are CSS element
selectors CSS ID selector CSS class
selector CSS Universal selector and CSS
group selectors so what is the CSS
element selector
the element selector selects element
based on the element name
this is a CSS selector it means it will
select all the P elements on the page it
will style all the P elements to the
central align having blue color
this is a CSS selector
it is set to P this means it will select
all the P elements on the page it will
style all the P elements to be Center
aligned having blue color
let's look at what it looks on a page
so as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned with the text color
blue
CSS ID selector
the ID selector uses the ID attribute of
an HTML element to find a specific
element
an ID should be unique within the page
so you should use the ID selector to
find a single unique element
to find an element within a specific ID
use a hash character followed by the ID
of the element
so here we have used the hash Paragon so
all the rules will be applied to the
HTML element with ID equal to para1 so
this is an ID selector
it will be applied to all the HTML
element with ID is equal to para1 as you
can see it is applied to the elements
having the ID paragraph and all the
other elements are defaultly styled
CSS class selector the class selector
finds the element with a specific class
set by the HTML class attribute to
select an HTML with a specific class use
a period character followed by the name
of the class so this style will be
applied to all the elements having the
class name class 1. this is a class
selector it is denoted by a period
symbol all the elements having a class
named class 1 will be styled with
centrally aligned and color blue
as you can see the element having the
class name class 1 is tiled and all the
other elements are set to default CSS
Universal selector
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a page the universal
selected is assigned by a star character
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a style sheet as you can see
it is generated by a star Mark all the
elements inside our page will be
centrally aligned and the color will be
set to Blue as you can see all the
elements are centrally aligned and the
colors are set to Blue CSS group
selector in stylesheets there are often
elements using the same style to
minimize the code you can group
selectors to group The selectors
separate each selectors with a comma
here we have group selectors for H1 H2
and P
so style is applied to H1 H2 and P
elements only
it is better to group The selectors to
minimize the code
here we have group selectors P H2 and H3
so style will be applied to only
elements having PS2 and S3
as you can see so all the elements of
PS2 and S3 are centrally aligned and
colored to Red in this video we will
discuss what is the Box model and its
various properties
we will also do an example to understand
the Box model better
so let's get started
every element that can be displayed on a
web page is comprised of one or more
rectangular boxes CSS Box model
typically describes how this rectangular
boxes are laid out on a web page
these boxes can have different
properties and can interact with each
other in different ways but every box
has a Content area and options
surrounding padding model and margin
areas
the following diagram demonstrates how
the content padding model and margin CSS
properties determine how much space an
element can take on a web page
the content area consists of content
like text images or other media it is
bounded by the content Edge and its
dimensions are given by the content box
width and height
the Border area is the area between the
Box padding and margin its dimensions
are given by the width and height of the
Border
the margin area consists of spaces
between the border and the margin the
dimensions of the margin area are the
margin box width and margin box height
it is useful to separate the element
from its neighbors
the padding area is the area
that includes the elements padding this
area is actually the space around the
content area and within the Border box
its dimensions are given by the width of
the padding box and the height of the
padding box
now let's jump to an example to
understand the Box model better
so we are on the sublime texturator to
get started I have created a box theme
simply run background color pink the
font size is 30 pixel and we have set
the border to zero solid green
let's see how it looks on our page
so as you can see we have a box named
simply learned with background going all
the way to the end
I have also removed all the padding and
margin from the page so that the boxes
are pushed just at the corner of the
page as you can see
let's start by adding a padding of 20
pixel to the Box
if you save the file you can see the Box
increased by 20 pixel from all the sides
inside the background of an element it
goes around the content of the element
most of the buttons inside the CSS be
designed using padding so that the
background of the button becomes wider
than the actual text
the next thing you can do is change the
border of the element so if you change
this border size to 15 pixel we will get
a nice solid background of color green
the Border goes around the padding of
our element so we have the 20 pixel of
padding around our content and 15 pixels
of border around the padding which is
around the content
now I will see the working of the margin
if you add 30 pixel of margin to an
element you can see the spacing on the
outside of our border
so let's add the 30 pixel margin and
refresh
you can see the spacing on outside of
the Border margin is used to space two
elements apart from each other
now let's change these values to see the
difference
let's make the margin 40 pixels
we'll make the padding 30 pixels
and let's keep the Border 20 pixels and
make it color red
let's put it
let's observe the changes
so as you can see our border now has a
red background the padding is 30 pixel
the margin is 40 pixels let's inspect
the elements to understand it better
inspects you can see the different
styles here in the computer tab you can
see the Box model
this is a Content area this is the
padding area this is the border and this
is the margin area
we have the margin of 40 pixels around
the border so you can when you click on
this area you can see the margin gets
highlighted
the body area gets highlighted of 20
pixels this is the padding and this is
the content
you can change the size of the content
by adding the height and weight
so let's try adding height and width it
will give the height 50 pixels and will
give the width also 50 pixels
just save the file
now when you refresh you can see the
content Area 15 to 50. in this tutorial
we will discuss everything needed for
you to get started working with grid
layouts
we will start by discussing what is a
grid layout then we will move on to the
features of the grid system and some
basic terminologies which will help you
understand the grid system better
in end we will work on an example to
understand the grid system
so let's get started
what is a grid
a grid of the setup intersecting
horizontal and vertical lines defining
the rows and columns
and what is the grid layout
so CSL grid layout is the most popular
layout system available in CSS
it is a two-dimensional system meaning
it can handle both columns and rows
unlike flexbox which is largely a one
dimensional system
you work with grid layout by applying
the CSS rules to both the parent element
which become the grid container and the
elements children which became the grid
items
the CSS grid layout excels at dividing a
page into major regions or defining the
relationship in terms of size position
and layer between parts of a control
built HTML Primitives
you can see this is the basic layout of
a grid system
like tables grid layout enables an
author to align elements into columns
and rows
however many more regular layouts are
either possible or easier with CSS grid
then they were with tables for example a
grid container's child element could
position themselves so they actually
overlap and layer similar to the CSS
position elements
so here are the features of the CSS grid
layout
they are fixed and have flexible track
sizes you can create a grid with fixed
track sizes using pixels
for example this sets the grid to the
specified pixel which fits to the layout
you desire
you can also create a grid using
flexible sizes with percentages with the
new FR unit designed for this purpose
you can place the items into a precise
location using the grid line numbers
names over targeting an area of the grid
the grid also contains an algorithm to
control the placement of items not given
an explicit position on the grid
you can define an explicit grid with a
grid layout the grid layer specification
is flexible enough to add additional
rows and columns when needed
features such as adding as many columns
that will fit into a container are
included
it also gives you control of overlapping
content
more than one item can be placed into a
grid cell or area and they can partially
overlap each other this layering May
then be controlled with the Z index
property
so
here the basic terminologies you should
know to work with the grid system better
the grid line is a dividing line that
make up the structure of the grid they
can either be vertical or horizontal and
resides on either side of rows and
columns
a grid column is a space between two
adjacent vertical grid lines
the size of a grid column is determined
with a grid template columns property
on the other hand a grid row is a space
between
two adjacent horizontal grid lines
its size is determined by the grid
template Rose property
the grid cell is the single unit of a
CSS grid
and in Grid design a gutter is basically
the width of the space between columns a
gutter margin is this white space formed
by the adjoining inside margins of two
facing pages in a book or space between
columns on a page
so with this let's now move on to the
Hands-On demo and see how the grid
system works in actual world so we are
on the Sublime Text Editor open with a
project with some basic background
Styles and nothing inside the body
you can see this is a basic background
style we have pre-applied this to have a
good look of the Box model
we'll start by creating a container and
wrapping our grid items in it so let's
create a grid and give it a class name
grid container
and inside of it we'll put our different
grid items so we'll just create
different grid items and give them a
class grid item followed by a clock
number they belong to
so that we can easily distribute between
them
foreign
so we'll have the five elements on our
page
foreign
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so you can see we have the different
grid items on the screen so there are
easy for us to visualize we have not
applied any styles to them other than
the visual styles
so we'll go back to our code
let's go back to the CSS styling sheet
so to create the grid we will open a
stylesheet we need to display grid on
our grid container so we'll select the
grid container and set the display to
grid
if you save now
you will see nothing changes this is
because the gray itself doesn't Define
any rows and columns for us to work with
it just they give the alignment properly
therefore by default it looks just
exactly the same to make the grid look
actually great we want you need to do is
Define columns and rows for a grid
so to do this you will use a set grid
template and set the column if you want
to set the size of the column we'll set
the size to 100 pixel and 150 pixel
now
if you refresh you have the 100 pixel
column on the left and a 150 pixel
column on the right and then the grid
captures our next row
but what if you want a box to flexible
size themselves according to the items
inside of them here we'll use a fraction
in it so instead of a 150 pixel column
we want one fraction of our size and
instead of 100 pixel we want the two
fractions of our size
so we'll just replace with two fractions
and this with one fraction
now if you save the file and go back to
the page
you will see the items on our left here
in our first column are twice as the
largest item on the second column and
that's because of the FR unit we have
defined
you can see the difference in the sizes
item one is the twice the size of the
item two
another thing you can do is with columns
is use repeat
suppose you want four Columns of a size
100 pixel wide you can just write repeat
command and inside of it how many times
you want to repeat the size
so we'll just delete this
and use the repeat
we'll set the number of times we want to
repeat and the size of the
columns
now if you save the file you will see we
have a four Columns of 100 pixel wide
we can do the same things for row
just set the grid template
rows and Define the size you want
now you can see we have the symmetric
size all around our container
if you don't know how large your grid is
going to be you can use the grid Auto
rows and this will determine the size of
all the rows that is added after the
template rows suppose we want all our
rows to be 100 pixels
so we'll just delete the grid template
rows
and set the grid Auto rows 200 pixel
now you can see all the rows are not 100
pixel tall
let's change our colon back to 100 pixel
and 150 pixels
so that it will be easier for us further
we'll just delete this grid Auto rows
now we'll talk about the spacing of the
rows and columns apart from each other
we can do this with the help of the grid
grab property grilled row Gap will give
some spaces between the rows similarly
the grid column will give you the spaces
between the columns
now you can see the gaps between the
rows and columns
now we want the same value for both The
Columns you can use a grid graph
property and mention the space
we'll just delete this two
and instead of it we will use just the
grid Gap
and set the
size to 20 pixel
now you can see the evenly spaces
between the rows and the columns
foreign
this is all you need to know about the
sizing of the different columns and rows
now let's talk about the positioning
items within its grid cells so for
horizontal positioning we could use the
justify items and we can set that to
Center
thank you
so that enters the each item within the
cell
by default it is set to stretch
you can also set it to start
or end
or space around
foreign
we will leave this to Center
to vertically position the content we
could use the Align items
the Ally items also accept the same
values
we can set it to Center
we can also set this one to start or end
just we'll keep this to Center as well
you can also align the entire grid
within the container
so let's get rid of these to just
demonstrate them in a proper manner
we could use a justify content and that
will align the content horizontally
within the container
you can also set this to start or to end
just set this back to Center
to align the contents vertically we
could use the Align content and the
aligned content also accepts the same
value you can set it to Center
or start
if you inspect the elements
but
you can see they are aligned centrally
between the container we'll just close
this
okay so this is everything you need to
know to get started with the grid layout
grid works very similar to the flexbox
but it allows you to match in terms of
laying your elements because of its 2D
nature in this video we will learn what
is the flex box and how it is useful in
designing the layout of the website
we will also try to understand the
different properties of flexbox with the
help of an example
so let's get started
what is a flexbox
also called flexible Box model is
basically a layout mode or model that
provides an easy and clean way to
arrange the items within a container
if you are using a CSS for a while you
must have used the old block model where
you assign width in terms of percentage
or fixed width and then use the float to
arrange the items on the page
suppose for example you want to earn
three boxes in a row
then you have to enter everything
manually from width height and to
padding flexbox can do all these things
with ease
some of the concepts of flexible Box
model is the ability to alter the item
width and height to best fit the
containers available in the free space
Flex model is the direction agnostic
which is different from the Box model
which is vertically biased and the
inline which is horizontally biased
flexbox works for both
flexbox is more Effectiveness more scale
layouts
so here are the main properties of the
flex
okay so let's jump to some code and
learn how these Flex properties work
okay so we are in the Sublime Text
Editor to get started let's add a div
inside our body here and we'll give a
class of flexbox container since this
will be the container where all our
flexbox item will decide
foreign
we will add another div and give it a
class flexbox item and one more class
flexbox item one which will help us to
understand which items we are referring
to when we style our elements
individually
foreign
let's just save the file and see how it
looks on a page
now if you save the file you can see we
have the box because I have already
applied some of the styles to these
flexbox items let's just see the styling
so you can see we have the items tiled
just a basic styling so that we get the
Box on our page
now let's just copy these and add two
more flexbox items and you will see we
have two more boxes on our page
just copy and paste them below
give them the class name flexbox item 2
and flexbox item three
just save the file
now you can see we have three boxes on
the page
Now to create a flex container
we will add display Flex to our Flex
container and this is how we create a
flex
box container
so here we will just add
display Flex
just save the file
now you can see all the items are the
same height and they are all in the same
row you will also notice that if you
shrink our browser the items adjust
themselves accordingly to fit within the
browser
now if you want to style the elements on
the mean axis we will use the property
justify content inside of flexbox
container let's make it a center
save the file
now you can see that all the elements
are in the center of the page
another thing we can do is if we want
our layout to have a spaces between the
elements we will set the justify content
to space between
you can see all the items are now evenly
spaced if you want to lay out your items
on the cross access we would use the
Align items property the default value
for this is stretch
if we want to keep the size of our items
we will use the center and then all our
items will be Center vertically
before flexbox aligning the items
vertically inside the container was
nearly impossible with flexbox you can
do it easily
now you can see the items are aligned
vertically inside the container now
let's just delete everything and we'll
just keep the display flat
now if you want to have a column layout
instead we will use the flex direction
and change it to column select Direction
column now if you refresh the page you
will see all the items are shown up in a
column
now we can start talking about the
different properties that can be applied
to our different flexbox items as
opposed to a flexbox container items the
flexbox contains only for laying out and
spacing between your items as well as
the positioning of your item inside the
container the actual flexbox item
properties are used to override those
item Properties or to apply different
sizing to this element now if you want
the first item that it does not shrink
when you shrink our browser we'll set
the flex shrink to zero to our first
item
so we'll set the flex
shrink to zero
now if you go back to the page
and try to shrink this
you see the first item Remains the Same
it does not shrink
now in the same way you can set the
items to grow in proportion with the web
browser suppose we want our Flex box
item to to grow with the as the page
grow and cover all the empty spaces so
we'll set this Flex grow to 1.
now you will see the all these empty
spaces are taken by the second item
let's say we want the second box to be
the center of the container instead of
stretching to full height we can use the
Align self property and set it to Center
now you will see that the alliances
property overrides the Align content
property of the container
you can see it is centrally aligned
so this is all you need to understand
and get started to work with the flex
boxes
I hope you guys enjoyed this video and
learned something new about the flexbox
and how you can use the text box to
create the dynamic layout for your site
in this video we are going to discuss
one of the most important topics of the
web development which is CSS display so
without wasting any time let's get
started
so what is a display property
the CSS display property controls the
layout of the element on the page the
default value of the display property is
block or inline
let's jump back to our Sublime Text
later to see the various display
Properties by using an example to get
started I have a really simple example
setup
as you can see inside my HTML I have the
two paragraph tags and I have a
formatting with the background color of
sand color and font size 30 pixels
as you can see this looks like something
like this on the page
the very first property we are going to
discuss is the display block property
the drug display values make an element
a block element
the block elements start a new line and
span the entire width of the viewport by
default like how P element behave
there are also line breaks before and
after these elements
the default value of the
P element is a display block
so here
this looks something like this
what display box does is it means that
it is going to take the entire width
given to it
this is going to force a new line above
and new line below it so you cannot have
something next to here now if you change
here this to
[Music]
the next property we are going to
discuss is in line the inline display
value turns any element into an inline
element
these elements will appear on the same
line without breaks
now if it says here this to display
inline now all the P tags will behave as
an inline element
now if you go back to our page and
refresh
you can see now this is an inline
element
the inline element takes a minimum
amount of space possible as you can see
here the cyan color takes the minimum
onto space to fit all the content inside
of this p
so this is what an inline element does
also all the inline elements are on the
same line
they share the space together because
they take the minimum amount of space
possible
there are no line breaks in these
elements and they try to fit as closely
as possible now one of the demanded fear
is we cannot change the height and width
of the inline element
if you change here height
to 200 pixels
and with 200 pixels and Save
just go back and refresh you'll see
nothing happens this is because in the
inline display property you cannot
change the height and width of the
element
the next property we are going to
discuss is the inline block value the
inline block value is a hybrid of inline
and block element elements assign
display inline block appears on the same
line with the other inline elements the
characteristics of inline elements
however inline block elements are also
like block element in that you can
change the width and height of the CSS
now if here you try to change the height
and width
of the element
just change this to inline block
now if you go back to the page and
refresh
you will see the height and weight
property works this is one of the major
difference between inline block and the
inline inline display property
the last name type of display we are
going to discuss is the display none and
this is a really straightforward display
property
you just delete this
and change the display to display none
now if you save the file and go back to
refresh you'll see both the element
disappears
the display name removes the targeted
elements and all its child elements from
the page this causes accompanying
elements to behave as if this element
does not exist in this video we'll
discuss everything we need to know about
CSS positioning
by the time this video is over you will
be able to position the elements in CSS
like a pro
so let's get started
first let's cover the theoretical part
here we will discuss what is the SS
question property and its different
types after that we'll jump to practical
example to learn how to work with these
properties
so let's get started
so what is CSS position property
the CSS position property allows you to
define the position of an element on a
web page the top right bottom and the
left CSS position properties are used to
determine the final location of the
element
there are four values that you can use
to set the position of an element on a
web page they are static fixed selective
and absolute
using one of the four values above you
can specify how an element should be
positioned you can also use the top
bottom left and right property so
further Define the element position on a
page so let's discuss each of the
properties individually
CSS static position
this is a by default position for HTML
element
it always positions an element according
to the normal flow of the page
it is not affected by the top bottom
left and right properties
it is important to note that having a
static equation is the same as not
setting the position property at all
the next is CSS fixed position
the fixed positioning property helps to
put the text fixed on the browser
the fixed test is positioned relative to
the browser's window and does not move
even when you scroll the window
the next is CSS related position
the relative position property is used
to set the element relative to its
normal position
the relatively positioned element
behaves the same way as a static element
except that it is now subject to the
values of the four other CSS properties
we will discuss each of them with more
detail in examples
now there is CSS absolute position
the absolute position is used to
position an element related to the first
parent element
that has a position other than static
if no such element is found the
containing block is HTML
with absolute positioning you can place
an element anywhere on the page
now let's move on to the example to
understand each of the properties better
to demonstrate the properties I have the
simple example setup currently we have
three elements with just basic curving
Style we have not applied any position
style to them
now let's click on this
element 2 and inspect it
just go to the computed
and type here position to see the
position of this element
so you can see the currently the
position is static
static is the default value of all the
elements of the page in starting
the next position we'll see is the
relative position
it works almost in a similar manner to
static if you go here and change your
position to relative
you can see nothing changes
relative Act is the same as static with
the only difference is that the relative
allows you to change the top left right
and bottom of this element let me show
you an example
now if we change here to
left
20 pixel
and refresh
you will notice the elements move itself
to a 20 pixel from the left
let's set the top to 10 pixel as well
you can see the element has moved 10
pixel from the top and even overflows
the element below this is because
relative position when applied with the
top right left and bottom actually takes
that element out of the document flow
so let's just reset it
next property we are going to discuss is
absolute position and this property gets
well along with the top right left and
bottom so let's make this position to
Absolute
and you can see the changes made due to
this by just
saving
the absolute value completely removes
the element from the document flow this
is useful when you want a particular
element to be a specific position but
you don't want to disturb the other
elements positioning
absolute position positions the element
inside the some parent container that it
can reference now just
let's shift the top to 10 pixels
you can see the movement of this element
[Music]
the absolute position always position
the element inside some parent container
that it can reference to
now if we change the hair body position
to relative now the this nav bar will
position the element according to this
body so if you go here and refresh this
you can see that this 2 is in its
relation to with this container
and this is the relative is very useful
next is fixed positioning which is very
similar to Absolute positioning with
some differences
so let's change this to fixed
and just save this
now you can see it completely ignores
this relative positioning and goes
entirely at the top
this is because fixed position elements
are always fixed based on the entire
HTML element
it has nothing to do with the parent
elements one unique feature of its
element is they stay in the same place
when you scroll
let's make the height here
to 200 vertical height
now if you scroll down you will see that
the element 2 will stay on the same
position
C the two elements is stick to the same
but absolute does not work that way when
you change this here to Absolute
you can see it does not stay at the top
now
this is one major difference between
absolute and fixed
so that's it you can see the working
with the CSS position super EV in this
video we'll discuss the differences
between both the layouts and we'll
discuss which one you should use
I will also show you both the layout in
a practical example without diving too
deep
so let's first understand the theory
CSS grid allows developers to construct
custom grids with more flexibility and
control than ever before
it is for two dimensional positioning we
got rows and columns here
whereas flexboxes for one dimensional
layout it is useful in allocating and
aligning the spaces among the items in a
grid container the flexbox layout
pattern makes it easier to design and
flexible and effective layouts
the grid is used for creating a more
complex and organized layouts on your
pages
whereas the flex items is used to design
the responsive Pages without using too
much of positioning or float in our CSS
code to work with the CSS grid layout
you have to add display grid property to
your element
whereas to create the flex container you
have to use the display Flex property
so this is the main difference between
the layout of the
grid and the flexbox
here in the grid layout you can see that
there are rows and columns with all the
header menu main right and the footer
included whereas the flexbox is only for
one dimensional positioning
now let's move on to the example to see
the working of the both the layouts so
here is an example of the web page that
does not have any function other than
some basic styling
here on the page we have a header which
is blue in color this is the sidebar
with a red background this is the main
content and this black color is a footer
of the page here you can see this all
these items are stacked on top of the
each other
in the code you can see um this is the
footer part of the page uh this is the
main content of the page
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
foreign